It's going right now.
This is it.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off the
number one sex toy from men.
Oh boy.
Buckle up bitches.
Because may Miller and our pal Ryan
Parsons are here and we're going to get
the nitty gritty.
We're going to dig deep to figure
out what the fuck is going down.
We're going to crack
some shells and get some eggs of wisdom.
Why in Parsons, Ladies and Gentlemen,
Ryan is a good buddy of ours and uh, uh,
a training partner and manager
and trainer of Jason Mayhem.
Miller and Jason May have.
Miller is. Hello, right.
One of my good friends from
the crazy world of MMA.
Don't call it crazy, bro.
It's like derogatory. It's
derogatory. Tracy's good son.
Boy. Make sure you know
image, son. Come on, man.
You're selling like crazy on that guy.
May Have Guy,
if you don't know a mayhem as he's also
hosting this this season of the ultimate
fighter opposite Michael Bisbing and uh,
it looks like it's going to be an
exciting season. Then December 3rd,
December 3rd, it's all going
to go down or May Hammond, uh,
Michael Bisping has a goal.
Old, old fashioned fisticuffs.
They're going to get in there and take
care of it December 3rd at the hard
rocket or notes the palms, which is
the best place to see fights, Bro,
if you've never been in
the palm. So fuck for real.
We'll sell out quick. But it's,
if you've never been there,
literally the best place in the world to
see fights, the palm, those, those rows,
like there's not a bad seat in the house.
It's really like pitched like at a
severe angle with the seats going.
The Sea Turtle. Yeah. And they were like
right next to the k gladiator stadium.
It's fucking amazing. It's the
best seats ever for sure. For MMA.
I everybody that right. You agree? Brian,
you've been to a bunch of fights there,
right? Oh yeah. It's tight. It's
like, it's like the perfect size.
You could actually hear every noise.
It's like a private MMA
fight with your friends.
Even though it's like 3000 people or
4,000 people or something in there,
whatever it is.
It's the best environment for fights.
It's perfect size and they give a, I
can't even say anything. You know you,
you know you're fighting a smaller
cage off. Yeah. It's smaller cage.
It's the WEC sized cage. Yeah. We use a
smaller cage because it's a smaller venue.
It's more difficult to, we
don't have like, you know,
I'm sure there's like parameters
that they won't go past,
but the cage is not always the same size.
We have two cages.
There's a smaller cage and
there's a larger cage, like
the king of the cage size.
I guess now indicating the case is
probably a little small. Tiny. Right.
Oh Man. It was like fighting
in a phone booth. I thought,
I thought, God, I'm like,
man,
they were like defendant.
It's like one step and you're right there
on the guide. That was back in the day.
That was Janky man. They all, yeah. It was
like literally shit would and then shit
like, uh, they had a it in the rain.
I remember going out there and think if,
you know what I mean? The case is cool.
But even when I was a
kid, I was like, man,
I don't know if I want to fight in
this. You know, like, I was like, good.
I like how the regulations came
where things are better now.
But back in the day it was like to, oh
that's cool. Just put some hay down.
They would make a fight right there.
But the way I always looked
at it as the candy canes,
they provided a very useful service. Oh,
they got a lot of guys fighting. I mean,
even if it's kind of a weird organization
are doing everything sketchy style on
Indian casinos only because when they,
when they were doing it,
they kept having fights even
when it wasn't regulated,
just because they were having
fights on these Indian casinos,
they weren't doing that. How many guys
wouldn't have gotten gigs? You know,
how many guys wouldn't have, uh, gotten
us some experience. And you know,
I don't think that people should
fight on the water, you know,
on the slip that wet and wild tea,
the cage if you've never seen it folks,
if you ever seen it. Uh,
no, but I've heard of it.
Fucking crazy guys were throwing kicks
and just fallen on their ass like there's
no way you could throw a kick,
you know,
you can barely throw a punch
as you move forward every,
I mean it was literally like some crazy
hot oil wrestling sort of a situation.
You only go to one kings wet and
wild. Did they only do it? Yeah,
they only did it last,
but no other,
other organizations have had fights in
the rain too. I know one did recently,
I forget what it was,
but not like this.
This is the most of it with
the whole cage for breaks.
Chill started slammed me into
the floor one time like were,
we were like 19 refi and way back
in the day and he slammed me,
although there's a good one
and he's family into the floor.
The floor broke through with bottles,
God down through the, I'm like, ah,
how do you keep fighting?
It was a weird thing where we like spit
back and the referee like, wait, wait,
wait over there in that
corner. I'm like, what am I,
what are I going to do right now? Like I
was like, this is the weird thing, right?
I'm sure he was thinking the faith
bang. I'm like, what the hell?
And then the referee comes
back and is like, okay, ah,
decided Florida's broken.
Just stay out of that area and then had
his fight again. I was like, all right.
And then it was like a gentleman's
agreement during the fight,
like circle over to that way and I'm
like, it's both stopped. Kinda was like,
all right over here, over here,
over here. It's like a street fight.
It was like a street fight.
Don't go by the metal thing.
No more like then Kimbo and famous
satellite dish in the back yard.
This is the same spirit. Same spirit
of all right, who's going to stay?
We're going to punch you totally fucking
base, but watch out for that thing.
You know, I still get asked about
Kim all the time. He's like, no,
the number one fighter. I get asked about
what I do like weird radio stations.
Yeah,
like you've,
I don't know the people and I call up
and they'd start talking about fighters.
Almost always some whatever
happened to that Kimbo slice.
That guy who was the backyard brawler
what was it about him that he connected
like he's black with a big crazy beard
and he seemed cool even though he's
beating the fuck out of people.
He was kind of a nice guy.
Like you shakes their hands
afterwards and he's cool.
So it's like you kind of can root
for him and he just goes out there.
Mr Debates on people,
man,
that was the one fight where he let
that dude punch him in the face.
Who's going to come, come to do is hitting
him in the face of God. Damn. If that,
I mean if that carried over into MMA,
could you fucking imagine
if he just started,
if he was really combinating Jones
could could've. You could've.
You could've put him against dude.
He could beat up. They tried,
but he was such a gap in the,
in the,
he was such a gap in the wrestling
area that he couldn't do it.
It's also not like boxing where this is
my feeling on that. It's like if you,
I don't think the guys are afraid to fight
and I don't think the guys are afraid
to learn,
but you can only learn so much and I
think if you're in a situation like a
boxing situation,
they would take a guy as a prospect
and people who would be intelligent,
people that were,
you know,
thinking about the future would invest
time and money in this guy and slowly
build them up slowly give him the fights
that he needs to make him look good.
The fights in each test is worth
when the guys, older guys, older,
just to just put them right in there.
It's also,
the mixed martial arts model is
very different than a boxing model.
That mixed martial arts model is get in
there and if you get offered a shot at
the title, fucking go for it. You
know what I mean? There's makes sense.
It's more exciting for the fans.
Yeah.
It's like a more hectic breakneck
pace that, but the little storyline,
if you want to call it that,
they go, you know what?
All of a sudden this is
happening. This is happening. Oh,
I'm checking on my Google.
You know,
everyone gets involved with a sport like
Shamar barely, you know, Shamar belly.
His kid was on the ultimate fighter.
Really good wrestler, very athletic kid.
He gets his first fucking official
fight in UFC. Evan Dunham,
very a tough guy.
Evan Dunham.
It's like he was like a couple of
steps away from the title shot. I mean,
Evan Dunham is, you know,
a high level, you know,
God and Shamar is a tough fucking fight.
A real tough ficus.
Kamar Bailey is tough as shit. Dude. The
guy took a ton of punches to the face,
but it was like real obvious.
They were like,
he really shouldn't be fighting
a guy at this level yet.
He should be building up to that level.
Right. So that's the up to their manager,
right? Yeah. It's hard. That's
why I was going to ask you,
how do you make that decision?
Like how do you make the decision?
I mean there's a, there's a decision,
well, you know, you got to test them,
you got to see what happens.
And then there's the other school
of thought where like, no, you, you,
you got to make sure that you know exactly
what level he's at and know exactly
what level the opponents at so you can
ensure that he's going to have a long
career.
If you can show that he develops properly.
Like how do you break that down in
your head? So many variables there.
It's so good. She's a great example. For
first half, he wasn't making any money,
so he couldn't really train
properly over a 10 week period. Um,
we had five fights fall through.
People look them up and go, nope,
I'm not fighting this guy.
If you don't know who Soju is,
he's a fucking crazy powerful judo dude
who made a big splash and pride and
pride.
Everybody thought he was like going to
be the second coming when he knocked out
hood cheerio with a wrist.
They're like Rista face hurting.
We were talking about this we, yeah, we
were talking about, we were talking about,
uh, you know, tough guys that somehow or
another it just didn't click for them.
You know, they just start off
real good. Like Darren Rona fight.
God Damn when he knocked out of Rona,
Jesus fucking Christ, it was like,
who's going to stop this
guy? I'm gonna, you know,
he looked like this freak
athlete man who just,
when he hit a run in with that upper
caught and blasting them backwards to put
them out. I was like, Jesus.
He's like, he's a fucking threat,
but then it just doesn't happen, man.
He get, gets in there against top,
top level competition and he
just can't keep it together.
How do you know that was top level
competition? Those two fights of Rona was,
yeah. Yeah. What? Prior top three or four
guy at that time. Yeah, totally. Yeah.
Why do you think there was
a big difference between
when he fought in pride and
when he fought in the United States?
I think that Majesco,
Jason speak to this two weeks too.
I think the experience of getting
famous and the pressure that comes with
winning big fights is a lot and
it's such a huge part of this game.
Is it king guys deal then I forget all
the fighting stuff cause you go into the
UFC. Joe Silva is not going
to, I know I've asked.
He's not going to give you easy
fights to go along. You go to the UFC,
you have to be prepared to fight anybody.
That's what makes it cool.
Nobody gets brought along there. Either
you're going to go make it or you're not.
We're going to find out real quick and
this is why we all get so excited about
it that that is one way to look at it.
But the other way to look at it is that
if a fighter water to develop to his
utmost the best way to do it with the
engineer it and that someone you know
would be able to
no, I'm, look, I'm just
playing devils. No,
obviously I support the
UFC the way of doing it.
But do you think you've been talking
on even talking on like the ultimate
fighter, like watch tonight.
Okay. That we picked the,
we picked the,
the fighters,
we picked the fighters and this first
episode builds up to the first fight in
the house. Now picking the correct fight
and the correct fighters. You know,
you always want to try to get
your guy a path, but guess what,
when the competition is high, there is no
path necessarily. You know what I mean?
Like, Oh this guy. But styles do make
fights. You know, you want to pick to do,
if you want to get your fighter
to fight this dude, you know,
because more than likely his style's
going to going to prevail. But you know,
mixed martial arts, anything
to happen, you know,
like that night is a different night,
you know what I mean?
How frustrating is that coaching guys?
What does that like? I liked it a lot,
but yeah, it gave me a newfound respect
for Ryan's job cause I was like,
Ryan's has got to yell at me,
like whatever.
He just fucking telling me to
ground and pound like I got it bro.
Just tell me what to do. But,
but like, uh, once you're
doing it you're like, Oh God,
in my whole brain like, ah, I gotta just,
why am I thinking about this dude
in the shower? Like I'm just like,
when I'm in the shower I'm thinking about,
Oh man,
I've got to teach this guy this move
or I've got to make sure he does this.
I'm like, oh, why am I stressing like
it's my kids? Yeah. And then I, but,
but man, you only got to do it one
dude. Man, you're lucky. It's hard.
You got to really focus on me.
He
said too,
it's like when you start looking at styles
and how these things match up and go
back to, so could you, it was a safe
fight for us because he got paid decently,
had no money and we were
paying him every month,
couldn't get any fights and we looked
at uh, um, um, what's his name?
Jose Mario and said, okay, he's got
good boxing. We're pretty confident on,
so could use boxing. The game plan was
to go play. The game plan was the fight.
We did that same thing over and over
again for six weeks with the thought being
is take them down to the ground and
worst case scenario for him here,
this will get submitted.
Well it's not supposed to win anyways.
He's not going to get hurt.
He makes a bunch of money.
He gets his name out there and we thought
that he was going to go win that fight
too. So you start to look at
who's the matchups going to be,
had those styles match
up against each other,
upside and downside and weigh it out.
Same Kimbo when he fought in Sengoku the
first time took a fight against Travis,
few on 60 days notice.
Well I knew what Mo is capable of and
Travis view wasn't a dangerous threat on
his feet. He wasn't going
to submit moe from his back,
go out there and shoot a double leg.
In my mind they're the worst
case scenario was okay,
he'll have a boring fight and he'll be
labeled a boring wrestler. You know,
no one wants to see him,
but for what they paid him a lot of
money for that fight risk or reward.
It made a lot of sense.
It's also hard for guys when they first
break in from other sports too, right?
I mean how hard is it for, for a guy like
mo who comes in from wrestling, it is,
you know,
just elite,
an elite level of wrestling and then now
all of a sudden he's going to deal with
striking Nelson. He's got to deal with
shit that maybe he's not as good at,
you know, as, as is his key moves.
You know, just depends on the guy.
I've been Jason, Jacob, Jason,
by speaking up there at Nika.
What? I don't even know. What the
hell are you guys talking about?
I just want to dance. Joe Rogan. I just
want to go. Don't we all see? Right?
Like just out of nowhere.
I just was very rare that anybody gets in
is the mindset of a a manager,
someone who trains fighters
and someone who coaches guys.
It's a very intimate relationship,
man. Are you kidding me? It's
like my brother. I want to
beat him up all the time,
but I want to hug them all the time too.
If he did wasn't him,
you wouldn't be you, right? Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, you got it. You don't have to latch,
Huh? It's an odd match, but
it's not funny. It's funny.
It's, it's a reality show.
The ultimate fighter season 14 for
you, Ryan. I mean, I've known you
years, man. It's gotta be a
maddening job at times, right?
I mean, I like the chaos
of, it's how my brain works.
What I finally discovered I'm really
good at is taking a whole bunch of shit,
putting it together and making
it all work really well. Yeah,
he's pretty good at that. So think
of what MMA and especially for Jason,
I have a huge creative side,
so especially in Japan,
whatever you do it here too bro.
We have like cool,
like creative outs like where we just
like, oh hey dude, what about this idea?
But other than that I don't look at me.
May have monkeys.com that's [inaudible]
monkeys about, that's her latest one.
I really
back to your opinion on MMA and when you
and I have conversations about stuff,
I don't think we ever disagree. It's
very, very rare. Like occasionally like
I would if we do it, cause I'm hating and
don't want to admit that to John Jones.
When you finally gave it on judge Joe,
he's a friend and it's
all a bit when I'm wrong,
that's a superman. That's a superman.
That's it. That's the Uber Manch does it,
dude, who's just on another level.
That's ridiculous shit to do that.
That may have after your
fucking training for four years.
Yeah. That may hammer
others. Rampage have.
That's pretty bad when you
look at a guy like that.
That's why you want to stay two one 85
yeah, you go like that tough ass bastard.
He cuts down from from
a good amount of weight.
He looked sucked down in the way in and
then he looks swollen his day like I was
like, wow, that's a
good weight cut. He did.
He does a good job of cutting weight
and he's fucking, anyway, he's a beast.
I mean,
but he does like a big long dude.
Like he does like weird Lanky Guy Shit
at two oh five oh man. Thank you bro.
I was getting annoyed that my boys, you
finally microphone is down here though.
That's rare. That's remember when that
Shit I was telling you and you were like,
oh, this is the most boring thing
you've ever said in your life.
What was that about? I was me tiling
the microphones down. Where is it?
Where's the microphone? Before the show
started, I was giving, showing him how,
where the microphone life.
He was like, Hey, I even started singing.
Yeah, you got to spice it up. Oh,
this is how he was talking. He
was like, hey guys. Okay. So, uh,
around to a different level of add.
This level of vd phone
is down at the bottom.
You have taught a bit like it's a cock.
Oh Wow.
Why did you cut both balls? Look
experienced. Turned beyond a little bit.
He's been the dog, Bro. I can talk like
this. Lord have mercy. That's right.
Lord have mercy. Okay, let's try to
pretend the people are actually listening.
Whatever people are missing.
Squirt bottle.
Sometimes I think two together
and make one. One awesome dude.
I figured out that means
you're actually kind of like girls. I like
to date though. Very big. Crazy bitches.
Insane. Grown to being
arrested. Huge. La. Really?
You want to take my name?
Are you holding it sideways?
Like against her? Now you're
my girl. I just liked it.
I spit bonds into this mic.
Sorry.
Joe Rogan look hurt you. Joey
d is singing. I am. I why? Why?
What's the matter?
Oh Man.
Watch he has will get mad at
you for not having pencils.
You don't have fucking punch holes in
your house. And Joe Rogan, I don't, fuck.
Do you write something down Hilton?
He'll sign something.
I know will not be let it go.
You got to let him just ride
out that storm and crash that.
You don't have fucking
pencils in your house. No. No.
The first time he did it to
me, I was confused. I was
like, are you really angry?
Are you joking? Are you joking? Are
you really angry? I was like, Oh shit.
He's really angry right now. Like
about Trump is doing. But no,
but just for a moment he just
goes into a blast. Like he just,
I understand that dude a little
bit like I put like, he's awesome.
He's just got to let it out sometimes.
Just scream in your car
in traffic for no reason.
Just screamed at the top of your lungs.
All of the most fun people are crazy
because just got to figure out what their
crazy is and maneuver around it.
Try to let them know, you know,
that's their writing. Yeah, yeah,
yeah, I know. Okay. Keep your crazy.
Hey Joe, I interviewed bready
today. Steven Brody Stevens.
He walked us through an Esther,
we home at your house. Oh yeah.
And we went through the
whole entire thing from start to finish.
For folks who don't know,
why don't you explain what happened?
Cause Brody Stevens, just tell us what,
we already pretty much got sick,
uh,
overseas when he was performing and he
decided to, to take like medicine to help,
like strep throat and a couple of things.
And he took stop taking his other
medicine, which was Lexapro. And uh,
he came back to the United
States. Uh, you know,
it was still six still taking antibiotics
but wasn't taking his medication and
then started to go on the, he, he,
he went on Tmz on hosted TMZ
for a week and he or, or a day,
and he said he was on Tmz as the host.
He took over Harvey spot for the day.
And then the next day he was having all
this positive energy about being on tour
on TMZ.
Uh,
and he started to like go to people at
Starbucks that were angry or mean or had
negative energy and would
call them out on their shit.
And then there was a video where he
called out a gang banger kid that was
hanging out in front of
the seven 11 scaring girls.
And so there's a video of him filming
like using his phone, filming like,
Hey motherfucker, these stuff freaking
out girls and screaming at this gang.
Like he was pretty much
attacking negative people.
And what happened is it got
kind of spinned out of control.
He was having a manic manic episode and
he got committed into a hospital wait
time out.
He was negative people where they
all negative or is he just like,
you know what I mean? Like people,
well complicated characters.
It's very interesting. We went really
into detail and, and cause the key,
one of the things he went to Starbucks
and did it like where this guy was like,
oh well I think what you
were saying negative people,
it's just what Brody exactly like.
So people could just be a dude trying
to get a fucking cup of coffee,
look like a gangster. We're, we're
establishing a Brody went crazy. So yeah,
pretty much. It's great boy. Now he felt
like it wasn't that crazy. No, no, no, no.
You know what mean fitness? No, cause I,
it's what I said is that if I was at
Starbucks and you just start talking to me
saying, hey, I like your shoes and
stuff, I might have not said what the,
what made them go crazy
with the guy said to him,
which was a please don't talk to me.
I would have said like, you know,
kind of amused it for a while and then
stop talking or you know, kind of on him.
But he, uh, it was very interesting
to listen to and now he's on,
he changed his medication and
now he seems like a very relaxed,
like kind of like he's
dissecting himself character.
And so we did this really cool interview
today. It's gonna be up later tonight.
But it really,
I can't wait to look at this cause I'm
really interested in this because for me
like man, mental illness is the
most interesting thing on earth.
I mean everyone has some form or some
variants of the normal human beings.
And to see this kind of thing like to
see like where this guy had the super
creative burst of like, you know, I mean,
what is that? You know, like that's,
that's crazy that uh, that we don't think
about that more. You know what I mean?
Like a lot of people can, if you're
smart and have a mental illness, you,
you can shift the world into a different
way of thinking. But theory about that.
Oh really? About human behavior
in general when it comes to that.
I think one of the reasons
why we were so unstable,
I think it's almost engineered to make
sure that we keep moving and then more
things get done because
I think that when things are stable and
when people are at rest and at peace and
calm, nothing, not much
gets done. Mutations. Yeah.
I think one of the reasons why
people fuck their own lives up.
It's like there's almost like a pole.
Like the universe has a pull
for you to fuck up to see you.
You keep making mistakes and keep
moving things in the same direction.
Make sure that things keep moving. Your
relationships always going to fuck up.
Your jobs are always going to fuck up.
There's always going to be,
chaos is always going to be things to
go wrong constantly and it's because
that's the only way things stay moving.
The only way thinks they moving.
And so you have to be flexible and pliable
as the world falls apart all around
you. Your success is dependent on
how you deal with that. Yes, exactly.
Just having this discussion
last night, it's inevitable.
You, you know, if, if you,
you either sink or swim,
like you're going to hit the bad lottery
sometimes get robbed outside, uh,
outside of your hometown,
that can happen.
I think that we're programmed to do
that. No, but I'm saying the bad stuff.
You're going to hit the lottery sometime,
but you can just got to power through it.
Just drive through this negative stuff
cause negative stop on your, you know,
on the road, learn from everything. I'm
convinced one part of self destruction,
not the whole part.
That one part is if you're not
growing or progressing in life,
you do something to create that chaos
where you have to do something to break
through. Absolutely. Oh yeah.
That's a good way to have
that conversation a couple
of times before and I
always admire the way you see it and it
really is that you will set yourself up,
you will give yourself shit to think
about. Right now. You can. Now,
what you do with that is depending on
the crash like your friend did or do you
use that for awareness and growth and
you can left coast in new planes really
can't ever stop growing. You can't.
If you think you stop growing,
you're going to fuck yourself. If you
say, this is that I'm done. I'm not,
I'm just not even gonna think about
things anymore. I'm not going to try.
I'm just going to relax and
you're going to get cancer
so I'm just going to go wrong.
Everybody got along great. Good.
I think I'm just going to get married,
have some dogs, you know, just chill out.
You got Cancer Board and you're
going to die. Keep moving.
You got to excite yourself.
There's got to just stimulate shit.
You know what I'm gonna Start doing
and we start going fishing. Why?
I don't go fishing and
people are fucking into it.
And I went to lake a steak the other day
and they're catching 25 pounds striped
bass. And I'm like, I want to catch a
fucking 25 pounds. Tripe Bass, boom.
More excitement, more good stuff.
That's where you got to do, man.
You gotta keep shit moving. The smart
people choose it though. Yeah. Yes.
Well you've got to kind of engineer your
consciousness in a certain extent or to
external extent. You know, he, you know,
there's a lot of people that purposefully
surround themselves with exciting
things, you know, cause they will, they're
like, fuck, I want life to be exciting.
I want to go even dumb shit. I want
to go rug with the bowls. You know,
running with the Bulls is
a perfect example of how
people insert excitement into
a life that makes absolutely no sense.
I get into,
I've never done it and I
probably would not, my thing,
if I was there and I was hammered and I
was pretty sure I could fucking run fast,
I might do it. I might know. I
might not. No, I wouldn't do it.
I would get real close and
then I ultimately, I'd be
like, I'd hear the bowls and I'd go,
what the fuck am I doing? I climb a wall.
You re you wouldn't, I would run
whatever I need to hold you there.
I wouldn't be like, no dude Bro, hold
me. And I would ask you to please not.
I'd be like, just coming.
They're coming, bro. You don't,
you're not even wearing a red funds.
Who's runs fast and you are a ball.
I would have to say a ball, no
shit. But yeah, but this, you know,
you gotta fucking dodge. That's
the whole thing. Just dodge. Yeah.
You got to jump a runaway from some
people that didn't dodge on man.
That shit looks so unfunded, but that's
the point. You don't want to be that guy.
I understand right that gate.
Sometimes it's going to happen but
you just don't want to be that guy.
Skydiving or Bungee.
And if you did and if you did,
you probably won't die and you'll just
have the scar and be like, Yo, I got,
I got hit by a bull. Like whatever. It
would be bad ass either way. You slice it.
Do you ever see that one video of the
bull just throwing the dude around like a
rag doll in a cobblestone street over it.
Over the guys heads is
flying up and bunking down.
Why is that conscious knocking down the
road stones has a fear of an overdose.
Irrational. It's irrational. A
friend of mine from Colorado,
our friend Ash Casey Atchinson just set
us up a picture of a Mountain Lion Jack
to dear near his house.
Fucking I know,
but 150 pound cat and then a dead thing
that runs away facet as you or I watch
his face Ryan, he's so into it when
he's talking about it like he gets,
so he like views.
He can see the claws coming at them.
I can tell they know why I've eaten a
pot and gone to the zoo a bunch of times.
That's why. Oh really? Yeah. Wow.
When you were actually there with the
animal is one thing like watching DVDs
when you're banked and that's
important. You know, it's huge.
But watching a real animals,
like a real animal in person,
when you're high that's, you get a,
you get a completely different insight.
When you actually see a tiger and it's
right there and you're looking at it and
you look in that its paws and you looking
at its body and you're thinking of an
American house cat and I'll fucking
bad ass. Those little things are,
I mean if a 25 pound house cat,
what did it kill you to be terrified.
He'd be fucking crazy.
Fucking 500 pound tiger man.
And when you get really banked in New
York, you're like right next to an animal,
you, you really, it's almost as close to
that animal attacking you as you can get
the other side of the glass. Well, shit,
that's as close as you can get without
dying or getting attacked. Whatever. Dude.
People do that on wild kingdom all time.
They just [inaudible].
I don't know. I remember the, I
remember the reruns on Saturday morning.
I remember that.
No,
but I just feel like those
animals from a different planet,
I don't have that fear. Like, oh my God,
this thing can kill me. I just think, man,
look at this thing. I know that I'm far
enough away from, from all that stuff,
so I totally take away and go,
man,
this looks like it's from
a different planet or a
different time. Like a giraffe.
It's books. When you look
close at it, you're like,
bad thing is alien because
it has like we like,
you know on TV you just
don't think about it,
but when you see it up close you realize
that this thing is from a completely
different it I don't get from giraffes,
I get it from crocodiles. Oh of course.
Yeah, of course. Well then
from a different time, like
when we were in the city,
we were in Sydney,
we went to that little a zoo thing that
was right in Tauranga Zoo and went to
see that giant crocodile there and you
saw that crocodile didn't you see the
words you want to go?
Jesus Christ and thing was fucking tough.
One they had was only like 18
feet or something like that,
but they get to be like 30 feet,
28 feet.
Like those things are giant man.
When I lived in north Queensland,
there was a crocodile in the
wildlife park there with him.
He had lost all of his teeth
due to fighting. So they,
because their brains are so small, they
go, they sit on their backs and you know,
they tickle them. They do all
cause they're real predictable.
So the guy takes a wooden stick and he
hits the concrete and he whacks the crack
it out over the nose with it.
And the sound was identical.
One time is one time his daughter
went in there and this was a huge you.
No way you could wrap your arms
around him. She slipped and fell.
Came across [inaudible] across her leg.
All of her abductor muscles
are leg is shattered ducks.
Your muscles just spring up. They're
gone. She turns. It bites you.
Then across the pelvis, everything is
she. She had 23 surgeries or something.
Dad jumped over the fence,
started beating the crocodile.
Let's use the only way
that she got out of there.
That's what the crocodile with no teeth.
Wow. Oh, he turn it or leg the Jello.
Oh, that's weird. Imagine that.
I knew why. You have to tell Joe
Rogan is story. Now look at him.
He's even more scared. I know, man.
There's no way UFC Florida. Nah,
there's alligators around. No,
we're not doing to you. I'll see you
in Florida. Dana. No, Dana alligators.
I lived in Florida. Man. I used
to. I lived in Gainesville.
We used to go to the, there's a little
pond there and we would feed them.
I think it was called Lake Alice,
and we would go there and we would
feed these fucking alligators.
They were everywhere. They ate a lady's
dog while I was there. Once you see that,
I didn't see it. I got there right when
people were yelling and screaming though,
alligator came up with Jack.
This lady's dog. No, no.
Apparently it had probably happened
before I got alligators. Is it,
they're like such a good form of life.
Did that same basic pattern of evolution.
I've been there for ever.
You know what I mean?
Like here's the animal like this that
will live in these areas that it's like
just made of armor and just has
one thing, a bite. That's it.
They're efficient. You know what they do?
They're super efficient. What did I do?
I don't understand exactly how reptiles
work. I'll just tell the truth.
Here's the big thing that they
don't have to eat for a year.
That's what I'm saying. They just
sit there and get money, get money.
He kept money to sit. Meg Give you
money for the sunken and water.
No water hall. Was that
sound snap? It's my teeth.
You on the ground? Crocodile rap bro. Yo,
my new crocodile
LP about to drop by him because
his bottled water, the whole
bite bitches about a water hose.
How we do biting bitch by the water hole.
I'm coming for you.
There's a one,
there's a fucking awesome video of a giant
Crocodile Jack and a Willdabeast from,
from a waterhole and this fucking
world to bees has to be, I dunno, five,
600 pounds. I mean, how bad
the baby one? No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Nother baby. My
friend, they got a full size one.
This fucking tried are slow crocodile.
Slow motion comes out.
It's enormous.
I mean it's fucking,
it wraps all of that will the beast and
just she just rag dolls that bitch into
the water and pulls in under
and it's like God damn.
Watch any alien movie.
Watch any monster movie.
That's way scarier than any
shit I ever saw a Predator do.
Just grabs his will that be snapped
all of it and whips in into the water.
That is like something
from fucking Star Wars.
I don't know how to do
predators kept her head Bro.
And your spine and they did have like
lasers and lasers. Yeah. Carvel scarier
the breath under water for over an hour.
They just go underwater and just let
it can go invisible dude. That's good.
Ah Shit Man. Dude, I miss old movies.
Why can't we be cool like that anymore?
It's tough to get a good movie these days.
I feel like if they did it all youtube
footage of like fucking the Predator
being like on Youtube, maybe
that would help. You know.
And I think it's eventually going to come
down to technology is going to get to
a point where an individual
person can make their own movie.
Like you're going to be able to make
your own movie with your computer.
You could probably pretty gum
pretty quick now. What do you mean?
But I'm saying with like special effects
and like cameras will be so cheap film
to be so cheap.
Hard drives me so cheap.
Computers be so cheap and the programs
that you're a publicly available to
regular amateurs for making movies and
putting the special effects are going to
eventually get to this
incredibly heightened state
where you're going to be able
to make a fucking avatar movie on your
own if you're smart and not if you're
smart, fuck yeah, but it's not
yet, but when that happens,
then you're going to see the most amazing
movies ever because it won't be so
many fucking roadblocks to
make an an awesome move. It,
it'll just your brain
and a team of people.
You do need a team,
you do need a team,
but you know what you don't need is a
bunch of people with money telling you
what to do in your movie.
And that's what happens.
I've seen it over and over
again. It's a weird thing, man.
What a bunch of people who
are not creative at all.
I want to influence the creative
process and that's what fucks movies up.
It's a flux TV shows up. That's
a fuck standup comedians. Wow.
But couldn't you say that
also that, that, that,
that relationship between
people who are cock block,
the creativity and that you think
that that has developed this,
you think if everyone was a creative
dude and not a dork during the crunch in
numbers. Oh I could.
Everybody was creative food.
This would be a fucking lazy ass
town. It'd be like you need, you need
a Dorky dude to go, okay,
this, this and this and that.
And so you had need that team
to sell it. Yeah, exactly.
Butlinda George you do
to create it. No, I know.
But if they don't cock block you at
sometime they feel like they're worthless.
Yeah. But that's not your fault.
That's why they chose that work.
The best shows are the shows where they
can't say shit like southpark southpark
are so gold.
Tommy's Angeles.
Every now and then they'd say they can't
make a cartoon where they draw Muhammad.
They'll say shit like that.
Cause they don't want to get firebombed.
That's like the worst thing
they've ever done. I mean I,
I don't think they have any influence
in the creative process to you na,
I mean from what I don't know those guys.
Right.
Do you think that comedy
central has anything? No. No.
They pretty much do whatever they want.
Yeah.
Because she was so successful for
so long but show so buck wild. No,
nobody's loved that shows
that shows the best observer on social
commentary right now cause they do it six
days out.
That is like the most,
those guys are the most amazing
dudes in show business in my opinion.
Plus they just want to
nine, 10, uh, Tony Awards.
And the only reason I know what a Tony
Award is because of these guys is a
Broadway musical award. They won
nine of those. I'm like, man,
those guys are genius. There's
some brilliant, and I and I,
this is crazy cause they, they've been
like a little team for so long, you know,
since like since college days.
So those guys have just been linked into
each other's brain for so long and they
got to such a good partnership. They
don't fuck each other over on anything.
It's crazy man. It's like they,
you know, it's great work.
Neither one of them lost her head and
that's rare when you get a couple of hours
together.
Those are the two guys.
Those are the geniuses behind South Park.
Probably hate people saying
that they, I don't think, yeah,
I think they're like whatever.
You know that South Park guys to the
normal person it means, oh south park.
Yeah I know that show.
But people who really know the
South Park guys on team America,
she never laughed harder. That was
like a standup. Right. You know,
in a standup comic is killing,
you know that feeling.
That was how hard I was laughing
at that movie. I was like,
this is the best movie of all time.
I'm really interested though is south
park to see what they're going to do this
season. Cause the last one at the
last season was like, like almost,
it felt like the last episode
of why, what was it? Uh,
there was a divorce. What's his
name? Stands Dad got a divorce.
They were divorcing at one co or Stan
Lee's moving out of south park and they
just made the whole episode seemed
like it was. Oh really? Yeah.
Maybe they getting bored. They
want to do something new. Yeah,
whatever the fuck they do. I don't
care. I'll watch it right now.
What if they start in their
own like 21 years old,
like they're all grown up though.
Funny fucking word and open up a whole
new set of Joe fucking being teenagers
and I would open up a whole set whenever
you guys leaking inside him for right
now,
just saying it seemed like a good idea
that I hope that that's not what it is.
You're all fired. You
got in trouble. He ran.
He just took a wild guess
to you told him he didn't
guess that.
Nobody guesses that would do that.
Those guys to do whatever they want and
they have such a loyal group of fans for
sure. I watch anything they do. Nothing.
Those guys put it out there. This is,
there's some things that I'll ignore.
Ignore certain.
There's like a certain
moves I need to go see.
I haven't seen the pineapple express
yet. What? Yeah, no, it's awesome.
I've got it on DVD. I, everybody
says it's awesome. I haven't seen it,
but if it south park movie comes out,
I'm seeing that shit.
We're that shit opening weekend.
Wait, they have one coming out? No,
but if you want to say [inaudible]
I saw drive last night.
Now you're gonna ruin it. If not, I don't
want to ruin no spoilers. I liked it.
I liked it. It was uh, it's, it's, it's
a real interesting movie man. It's very,
I don't want to,
I don't know how to describe it without
giving a lot of the plot away, but it's,
um, it's a weird movie man. The
guy plays is really detached,
sort of a stunt car driver who gets
hired to do bank robberies and shit.
He gets hired to be the getaway
driver. I'm liking it. It's a fucking,
it's a good script. It's a good movie.
So there's a lot of good shit in it,
but there's a few, what the fuck scenes,
but that's you from what the fuck?
What the fuck are they doing?
Come on.
Like when someone does something like
someone's been cautious, the whole film.
Right. Then there's convenience
scene where the guy gets
to get them because he's
turned his back to him like a, like
a Newb, you know? I hate unrealistic.
That's annoying.
Then I know that you're just trying
to wrap up a movie right quick,
man.
Skin still got 90 minutes,
90 minutes in the air when
people's acid start getting sore.
Let's wrap this fucker up. There's a
lot of movies like that where you just,
you're halfway in the movie. You're
like, wait, wait, what? What do you do?
The fucker you ended in this like that.
Like that movie, the Bradley Cooper Movie,
limitless. Like back when we
were like, that movie too.
I liked it up until the end. We're
all of a sudden, he's like, well,
I engineered the effect shout.
No, I'm fucking awesome.
I want her to feel drugged out.
I can't get off the shit.
It was a cheap way to end it.
It was like, Hey, I fixed it.
I fixed it and now it's awesome forever.
What could,
what could be the alternative really
though? What does he go? Come on.
And he's a billion alternatives and
often in a number of different bizarre,
direct shitty at the end
of that off the movie man,
didn't you wish you would come
away like I came away like man,
that movie was great and tell
people it was great. I had a good,
I think what could have
been real interesting is
towards the end he could have
started having psychotic episodes where
he woke up at different stages of his
life. Different days. It was
different things. Oh one day,
one day was him before the
pills and it was all fucked up.
The next day it's him running the company
and he doesn't know which one it is
everyday wake up in a different felony.
Long as you could do that back and forth
with a few scenes over the course of 10
15 minutes and free people the fuck out.
I know when it goes to black and you go,
that guy just frying his fucking noggins
show rogue it presents he oh limit and
limitless pills and woke up in
between worlds. Haven't seen,
that's how I would end it.
But I smoke weed bit.
Did you say you watch breaking bag?
Yeah. I love that you just started it.
Everybody's mad at me because
I was quoting something
about how much I liked an
episode. It was the first season. That's
what I watched. I watched it on the DVD.
I didn't watch it live so I'm still,
I'm way behind.
I watched him when I get tattooed and I
haven't been tattooed in a few months.
I just saw the first episode, the
first episode [inaudible] Sashi Sleeve.
Is that your name?
Shit.
I know we've got some cool tattoos.
I always look back and I'm always like,
man, I'm sorry I didn't get any
tattoos. You still get them.
Some people like them,
some people don't.
The way I look at it as
like skin looks cool,
but I like art better and be
like art on my skin. You know?
As long as you trust the artist and
you have an idea, it's really good.
Like the guy that I go to,
Erin Dellavedova, it's fucking
awesome man. And he does,
he specializes in like really big,
beautiful pieces. I mean, he's this a,
I'm a fan of his artwork. Like if a
Yoda was his studio where he tattoos,
he's got all his paintings and shit
around. And how cool is that guy? Yeah,
he's awesome.
He's going to do the podcast.
You ever thought like when
you're eight years old though,
and if you don't get it touched up,
you're just gonna have a rainbow
on look like shit. No matter what.
Who gives a fuck?
I'm going to look at like an 80 year
old dude who did some crazy shit.
It's all right.
You'll be in bed by six 30 and be
in bed by six 31 out on the corner.
They're going to call you
rainbow to break. Joey d is
when I'm 80. I just fucking,
just going balls out to the
fucking wheels fall off.
But um, he's, I got to get him to finish
this thing, man. I've met somebody,
he's like uncle Louie or something
or uncle George. Uncle Benny,
uncle Benny, man. He had like
an old school with tattoos,
probably like the Fayler Dan
Hardee before that shit hard man.
And he stole the knife at, uh, at,
he stole knife at Thanksgiving.
It was weird. He just got like,
yeah. He was like, where's the knife?
And he was walking around the house
with a knife in his hand. Man,
somebody get uncle Benny each week.
There's nothing creepier than a drunk
person is. What a knife. He wasn't like,
he was like dying.
You see now he wasn't even drunk
uncle.
I was with Chris Mcguire once,
I mean Chris Mcguire and when we
were hanging out with this dude,
there's a dude that used to own up
laugh, uh, the comedy Improv in Tempe.
And uh, there was a dude who was friends
with the owner, took us to his bar.
We're all hanging out at his bar.
We're going to go back to his house and
he said by the golf course, a beautiful,
we're just having a party at this
guy's place. Seems like a cool guy.
We all go back,
go back with a bunch of his friends
and all these different people. Well,
it turns out to be like one o'clock in
the morning and the guy is shit faced
beyond like you can't even
make eye contact with homeboy
and he's walking around
with a pair of scissors because he wants
everybody to leave his house except
this one girl and the girl was
like 19 years old and she was like,
please don't leave me here and
please don't leave me here.
Like this was like running around
his house,
kicking these people out that he just
invited in with a pair of scissors.
It was one of those moments. It was me and
Chris Mcguire. Was he on your Facebook?
That guy? Yeah, we're besties now.
I mean we got through this little dark
moment with him trying to stab people for
19 year old rape
pussy
girl and the girl looked at us,
she goes, please don't leave
me here with him. We're like,
we're not going to leave you here.
Could you come over to us?
And we had to like argue with the
guy. We got to show us. Look Dude,
she wants to leave with everybody else.
We got to go. Let her go. Just hold it.
You know,
there's one other couple that was watching
that used to live at home, but this,
we were close enough to get stabbed.
Not I'm saying, but what feel,
how does a crazy guy, I think some people,
I've seen it happen more than once.
Some people,
whatever it is,
whether it's alcohol or drugs or there's
some things that they take that make
them snap over and they're gone.
Ceville you see that glassy eyed look in
their eyes. They're not really, they're,
they're, they're, they're rational.
Conscious mind has completely shut off.
I've seen it with alcohol.
Some people, yes, alcoholics.
I have a friend who was an alcoholic
and every time he gets drunk, you, you,
you were very likely to see a
different version of him and he's very,
very likely to be someone
who you can't even recognize.
You barely know what to expect from them.
They're going to say crazy shit to people.
They're going to get in trouble.
They're going to start fights. They
don't even know who the fuck they are.
They don't know that I've seen it.
I used to think it was bullshit.
I used to think we don't want, it's just
weak. People that are just, you know,
they don't want to take responsibility
for their actions. So they go, Oh man,
I blacked out. Oh man, I just got so
fucked up. I don't know what I'm doing.
I don't get that because I don't get that
drunk. I get drunk, but I'm me drunk.
I don't snap over. Some people do
though. They fucking for sure, dude. Man,
I've seen it and I know
you've probably seen it too.
They dance with the devil and
all of a sudden, you know,
there's some people, there's a different,
you know, like some people say, man,
I can't smoke pot. Okay, I understand.
There's people that can't drink.
They fucking can't. They just can't.
Everybody has their own biological thing.
You know, there's a reason why some
people are allergic to peanuts. You know,
some people it's, you know, it's
fucking tuna fish. You know,
there's weird things that make people's
bodies react. I can get it, man.
I can get it, man. He's hammered on
tuna fish. That guy is such a Dick,
right?
Like fucking every time he drinks the
juice out the kid like pushes it and I
don't think if you were allergic to
it would make you hammered. Yeah.
I don't know how you made that,
but have you ever seen them
blessing your connection?
You ever seen a list of like things that
you're not supposed to give dogs like
that are completely poisonous to jog,
but there's range on there like grapes?
No,
I'm calling bullshit on grants bro.
My pit bull used to eat grapes like
crazy. Yeah. They were like, I don't know.
I think someone started that Internet
fucking Roemer. I went through a dog,
a dog poisoning recently.
So I was given a list of,
of things that not to give your dog.
And there was some things on there
that I just would never have thought of.
Things like, uh, I can't even remember,
but it was something weird like
that. Grapes or nuts. There's some,
like if you give like a certain
kinds of nuts, chocolates alert,
they're allergic to chocolate.
So the cocoa, Oh and here's,
here's another thing.
Did you know like plums or like anything
that has a core in the middle of it and
it's like really,
really poison.
So like if you have trash and
the dogs going through the trash,
lot of times they like
to chew on like the,
the core of like a plum or are
you trying to say huh? Yeah,
it's got like a chemical in it that
I tried to say that you killed
your ex girlfriend's dog. No, no,
I'm not saying that happened
at all, but uh, well hey,
but I gave my dogs a plumbing.
Didn't matter. Players
aren't killing the dogs too.
Shit would have heard of that.
Right?
Everybody would know by now that dogs
eat their own shit and then run the
quarter mile away. Fascinating.
Well, usually if they get sick,
usually if they get sick or eat
something, they usually throw it up. So,
but they will still ask the dog run a
quarter mile after eating three or four
large mouthfuls of shit.
Dog
fucking fly. Yeah, you're
right. I'll show you.
Couldn't even fucking help to
keep up with that shit eaten dog.
Mouthful Shugg g shit breath.
And Shit smeared over it.
Shitty gums,
shit on his lips and he's running
like a bullet with no problems.
Not even a little hint of
bias. Your pantomime is our
point there. Good. Fuck it.
That's exactly how it'd be.
Poppin right there. Yeah.
Miles a day till fucking four legs.
You can't fuck before an exit. Period.
Fecal matter in this because it's
an exponentially faster animal.
Four legs.
There's a whole body whip effect.
They get a lot going on that we don't
have. My hot dog dog can jump. I bet.
He's like no. His whole body, he
bring you up right in the spring.
You told me the story of a, you got into
a physical fight with your massive ones,
right? It's true. Massive
fought for 30 seconds,
30 seconds, whatever. Fucking,
how big was it? 150 pounds.
That's how big it looks like a
little bigger than my dog, man.
How did this shit unfold? That's
playing. Otherwise it was,
we were young. It was 2124
years old. You get four or five.
I was like, wait, you were the math.
I made mistakes in the past.
Like
one day I just gave him his food in there.
I contacted him and it was on, you
know, I should have known him, man.
He's a dog. Can I contact
him and challenge his space
where he giving him food?
Don't look at them. Listen, here's
your food, bitch. You don't do that.
They give the dog,
you pat on the back and you walk
away. Make it makes always make contact
with the dog while he's eating this food.
So he's comfortable with that.
Doesn't think you're going to steal
food from when you touch them.
That's what keeps that,
that when some dogs and you touch them
when they're eating and they turn on you.
So what was the catalyst?
Yeah, I started off the Bra.
Dan Henderson had intact to pitbull who
lived with us and they fought probably
20 times. Oh my God.
That day, the day that
you guys are like, how many matches
have to go on this so far? It's crazy.
[inaudible] we got to get rid of the
dog. It's like one dog's got to go.
I love pit bulls,
but I laughed my ass off when people
tell me that they're not dangerous built
the kill we talking about. I love them.
They're my favorite dogs of all time.
But if you've had pit bulls,
you know they're dangerous as fuck.
It doesn't matter how much you train
them either is lying to themselves or or
you know like trying to lie to you
make them feel better about it.
A pit bull that I trust,
I don't care how much you trained it.
If it has it's balls and to mail.
I trusted around another dog.
I just don't, I don't, especially
if the other dog has his balls,
especially the other dogs,
a male and it gets even a little frisky
and especially if it's a Neal fighting
Brianna, some big crazy always dog
so that they both had balls. Wow.
About danger zone. That's too too wild
monsters or he had two handfuls and they,
I got so good at stopping the dog fight.
Excellent.
Then I could actually pin both
of them down and I need that.
You're wrestling really came about.
If you were a guy that didn't know how
to use your body weight things down,
did you get like under hooks on your dog?
Like I hold technique.
I didn't really neon belly or one
throat and pinned the other one.
Dan and I couldn't sometimes.
Most of the time I needed help,
so it just started calling
for whoever's there.
Then you had to go reach in
each dog's mouth and open them,
which isn't that hard to do actually
all that's why I'm not at all afraid of
dogs. No, it's really not
clamped down. Once you open,
if they shut down on your fingers,
but even thought they only have one
weapon, you know it's coming. Yes,
but still it can get you,
you know that's like Henderson right
now I'm with Brian [inaudible] gets you
just keep, you have to shove it into
their maps and then if it got really bad,
I just start poking holes.
Hopefully they have a collar.
I took my dog out when I was trying
to kill my cat ones with his collar.
I got neon belly and I choked him out.
I can put in my sleep and wait with
this color. Yeah, it was college.
Did you do like cross your hands a bit as
I got inside and put him in one block
composition position. Very good.
Mic Cooks make, make note here. I
put in a finito belly and I turned,
I turned it all. He'd go out.
Did Doug, you sleeping good now?
Plum pit texts at cyanide in him in grapes
cause kidney failure and dogs. Wait,
so you're telling me if I ate pumps, the
middle of it, the guy listen to this man,
I would die. It depends how much you
eat. If I work with, I'm sorry I do that.
I work with, this is going,
I got to before, forget this
guy.
His mom died from fucking Tylenol.
This mom got liver poisoning as your mom.
She died because he was taking Tylenol,
which has like whatever the fuck the
chemical it has and it also exists in some
other cold medication that she was taken.
She was taking the two of them at the
same time and she had fucking liver
failure. Oh that's wrong. Yes you did.
You know that that was even possible.
Every drug you can die from
mixing certain things like lot of times
if you look on something and say don't
take whatever that chemical
is in town with that,
I think it's like Apha Firebird.
I mean [inaudible]
have your input.
100,000 people a year die from
appropriately prescribed medication.
We know it just surpassed car accidents.
Yeah.
Most recently prescription drugs have
surpassed car accidents for a accidental
deaths for the first time.
They don't do stet when especially
when people take you take five drugs,
you ever been 100% chance of having an
adverse reaction to it? No one did appear.
Have you studied good double blind
controlled studies on those four or five
drugs together? That's why I only take
Alpha brain and nothing else. Yeah,
on a.com oh and it, oh yeah, I've
got to plug your shit seriously.
Joe [inaudible] it properly
because this this thing,
okay, I really wanted to hate on you.
I'm just going to tell the truth.
I'm going to,
you know what I mean?
Cause I did the cool guy shit and I went
online and I bought all my uh, you know,
kind of what you got in there separately
and I, okay, this is a good mix for me,
but I don't know,
did I took that stuff and man,
I smashed people at video games yesterday.
I mean that's my gold standard.
My brain was focused. I was
watching the video games, clothes,
like I think about it,
but I was like a robot.
I feel like it's like a mild Adderall.
Like I, I don't feel like I'm on anything,
but I feel so focused and I have to reveal
though that there's been a few people,
very small number.
Most people like the vast majority,
over 90% of all the tweets and emails
I get are positive. More than that.
You said it's like 99 I would say it's
like 100 101 I hate on you though.
Made me,
but one out of a hundred,
they don't seem like their hate
and they just say it. Dude,
it did nothing for me whatsoever.
And I believe that. Yeah,
everybody's got their own.
Some people. First of all,
I got to know where you're at. I don't
know. Are you smoking cigarettes?
So you got to shape, are you ill? You
know it was $29 half your paycheck.
That could be it too.
A lot of people are upset at the
price and this is what I said,
I said real clear. Yeah. I said, listen,
this is the highest quality shit and
we get it from the best manufacturers.
We put it in a really well calculated
form, but steal it, steal it.
Go online and see all the ingredients.
Go get your own ingredients.
I have scoop it off the shelf.
Well do that. If you can't,
no, don't do that because somebody
had high it. Man, that's rude.
I had to steal the formula. I
don't know man. I don't think,
okay if 29 bucks and not that
expensive for that kind of thing,
it is all the, all the uh, all the other
stuff, buying the stuff separately,
costs a lot of bugs and it's the
quality of all this chemical stuff.
If that mixed doesn't work for you when
you lost 29 bucks. They know what I mean.
Like so what? But you know, I dunno
the benefit for me man. I'm stoked man.
Well mine's, I'm stoked about it
cause they have a super clear,
I did an interview today.
I was like okay my brain works and
that was after training for two hours.
So people don't want to
believe in it and that's fine.
And there's a lot of people
that say there's no science
behind it, but there's a,
there's a science paper on the site.
It shows with references. It's a,
a medical editorial written
on the efficacy of this
Alpha brain stuff. And it's,
it's based on reactions man. It's based
on things that people have noticed,
you know, hey you take this, this happens
and put it all together and it has a,
as people get annoyed cause we talk
about it all the time. But I wanted to
talk about,
well people talk about,
I talk about also people being annoyed.
What does that knows? Is that your phone?
Someone's phone. That's
fine. That's your phone.
People being annoyed that we
talk about it. But I wanted,
I wanted to get your take on it,
which is why I had them sent. Right.
Are they gonna are they gonna sell
them in bulk? Like huge container.
We will eventually. I think that's
the way to go. Like 10% off.
If you go to Joe rogan.net there's a link,
you click on it and enter in the code
name rogue and you get 10% off of it big.
Now let me touch your beard bro. Oh
I just cut it off. But um, so, um,
so when you, when you took it, how many
days a week did you take that shit?
I'm taking it for four days. Did you
notice it right away? Pretty much.
I'm excited because I've
only been gone for four days.
I want to see what happens later.
Like I'm like,
cause I was feeling very
like I don't know man.
Whatever I say I say
that stuff is awesome.
I don't know how the hell
you figured that out.
It's not mean it's a Aubrey our buddy,
he's the smart one. Alright. Cause.
Yeah cause I'm like, oh I feel like
man, pretty bogus. It's pretty awesome.
Like I, I feel good that my friend
made up something that was good,
like way better. Like the like a,
that movie warrior was good. And My,
I'm friends with one of the guys who like
wrote on on the thing and I was like,
ah, I hope this is good. And I
thought like, man, that's really good.
I feel good when my friends and now
you give me these fricking pills.
And I'm like you sure that's not
a placebo effect. No, I know.
That's what I'm worried.
That's what I'm thinking.
I'm really trying to in my head go,
okay he goes the other way every
time I go all the way. Yeah.
I go and some bullshit a bullshitter.
Don't think it is. It's true.
I think recently I've, because you
gave me that new bottle and it,
cause I was out for like two weeks and
for those two weeks I was starting to
feel icky again.
And then I've been taking it nice.
I hope it doesn't get put on a PDS
list. I don't think a woman, it's all,
it's all vitamins. I know, but
what I'm saying is, you know,
if I have a brain advantage, yeah,
well it's illegal to right vitamin B.
There's some other shit that we're selling
now that's a based on the courthouse
steps. Mushroom. Do you know
anything about that Shit, Ryan?
Cause I know you're [inaudible] I didn't
know that you will. I didn't know that.
That's what it was when you said it. I
didn't realize cordyceps was, uh, was, um,
I had a lot of through
federal court is sentiment.
And earlier in my career I saw
that, yeah, I could, uh, I use it.
It helped my weight. And, uh, and what
do you call it? Uh, uh, and my cardio.
So I remember I was doing judo tournaments
and doing Jujitsu tournaments when I
was young. I would take that stuff
and it made me feel real good.
That's crazy though, that, uh, I didn't
even know that cordyceps mushroom.
I was like, someone said,
you've got to take course up.
So one of the trainers there, and I was
like, all right, I'll take it. And then I,
uh, I didn't put the hell is the
court itself, what does it look like?
Is it like a little blue mushroom?
What does it look like?
What's the court is set as a good
question? Google that come on.
Mushrooms are so fucking good for you.
There's so many mushers. I take Chaga,
mushrooms, those asked me really
good for your immunity. You know,
I take a bunch of different things.
Just knowing that I'm going
to go on the road a lot,
I'm going to be around a lot of, you
know, you know, icky things and you know,
so I take a lot of probiotics,
but I also started taking these Chaga
mushrooms because I read up on them like
how, how good they are and
many health benefits mushrooms.
What does it do for you?
Oh,
there's so many different things that
it's good for your immune system. It's,
it's like an antioxidant or like when
would the best thing about probiotics?
Anything that you're taking a mushroom
man, I always drink those or the little,
you never drink it the little,
um, what's it called? Yeah,
yeah, yeah. As Eva things.
The bio kids. Yeah. Bye. Okay.
Oh, you have it tastes good
there. You could tell man,
you feel digestive like you feel
like it pushes up by far by far.
What's it called again?
They're in the refrigerator.
They quick little yoga. Tiny,
a little canister. Loved the idea taking
all this live shit into your body.
I love what I was going to say.
Let's Kombucha drinks all those guys.
I love those things. Drink that shit every
day. Yeah. And it's really done. And, and,
and um, I also bought some fucking
ridiculously expensive acid alpha list.
I was like, why is he shit
a hundred bucks? You know,
because it's in the frigerator.
It's supposed to be like
the highest count, blah,
blah, blah, whatever, you know, different
types of, more like, all right. You know,
I'm not even going to do any research.
I'm just going to pop one and what a
day and see what the fuck is up for 100
bucks. It was like 100 bucks for a bottle
of like, not even how many times. Oh,
it wasn't that big man,
you know?
Have you seen the documentary fat,
sick and nearly dead guys nearly done.
Yeah. That's crazy. Yeah, exactly.
Because it's all about how that we
don't eat anything live for really,
we're getting all our nutrients from
dead stuff like, you know, like uh,
breads and whatnot, you know,
through all of America. Pretty much.
It's easy accessible thing and
to just juice all your food.
Everything's real life vegetables,
you know,
and people have done like juice
fasts and stop and gone on.
I did it in the movie 60 days with only
like he had a portable like juicer and
stuff.
And then he met people on the way in
the met his trucker that was like bigger
than Joey d 400 and he, and then
he started doing, he's like, look,
just do this for 10 days.
And next thing you know,
it was just like people were
dropping weight. He immediately look
helper, like feel a lot of, I mean I
tell everybody if you could do that,
you know it takes a lot of time and a
lot of devotion to like grind up all your
food in a juice, you know, it helps
me out a girlfriend. Do you think the,
you should use it or do you think you
should use that Vitamix thing? Yeah,
the Vitamix blender. It's basically
like juice in it. But you're also, yeah,
maintain all the stuff from the back.
A lot of the fiber that you both
trust me dude. But that fiber drink,
that's like your real drink.
Like when you grind everything up.
But like a Vitamix blender.
It's just, that's like, okay,
I'm drinking this and for me I really
like it now cause I know the health
benefits if you feel good when I'm
drinking. But when you drink it bursts,
you're like, man, that's
like lawn mower juice.
Like it just came out of
the juice out of the bag.
It's fresh out of the bag and
they blended a little bit more.
I mean suck it down. I've got the
regular juicer. It's just like,
it's like a juice. You're like,
oh, I went to w, uh, top of juice.
I tried to get my little kid to try it.
Oh yeah.
She looked at that fucking green sperm.
It looks like hulk sperm.
That's what it looks like it does today.
She says no,
she's always talking about loads.
A little kid
or something that triggers
my daddy's health drinks.
Brian's little daughter
healing fricking hell.
[inaudible] juice from six
months old. Wow. That's cool.
With the same stuff that blended up stuff.
The Vitamix thing just to get a juice.
Oh No, no. We, my daughter drinks
juices we'd get from the press.
Juicery there's a place that they use
some sort of crazy hydraulic cold press.
Something that is better than
grinding it out. It'll grow.
Lamar juice that little, his
little girl, she has a crazy dot.
Well her diets, amazing cooks.
Everything from home organic. She
never had any meat or dairy. Really?
Yeah Bro. It's weird. She's never,
she's been sick probably three
times in her whole life. Wow.
No meat or dairy, Huh? It's so
crazy to see his little kid.
Cause usually I see little kids that are
like sticking them out and Donald's and
this kid is like super healthy eater and
like man it's really crazy to see how
that benefits a kid.
For sure.
Traditional bag cause I could tell this
kid is like she'll never sick. Awesome.
And like really like I dunno,
she at least gets the way ice
cream once in a while or anything.
You come out really great ice creams like
um, any of those cashew nut ice cream.
I love her stuff. I would
never go. No dairy cheese is
just too fucking delicious.
I'm sorry,
a steak and cheese with no cheese it
with some fucking whack ass vegan cheese.
Get away from me sir.
There's a corner in Philadelphia where
they have to steak and cheese place
before. Is it patent Geno's
Geno's is it Pat's the other one?
Somebody tweeted me the go away.
They know what the fuck they're doing.
They know what the fuck
they're doing and cheeses.
It's very important that like
real east coast, east coast,
give me that thing that they could choose.
And for a lot of dudes it's like 2:00
AM they struck out as bars and then
they're like, let's see what we can
get over the steak and cheese players.
Remember it's your pussy. You know what
I'm saying? Just get hammered and go eat.
That's one that's just delicious.
Yeah.
There's nothing better than fucking
greasy spoon you're handling. Oh God.
Just give me whatever it is.
Cheap ass.
Fucking Pastrami. Reuben from Jerry's
Deli. You know what I'm saying?
You know that feeling,
those those Pastrami Reuben's where you,
you lather that fucking,
what is that?
1,000 island dressing on the inside of
that bitch and just exploding in your
mouth. Just orgasm. Oh,
cheese and fucking sauerkraut.
When you're hammered, man,
there's nothing better than that.
People who've never been hammered or
high really don't understand what food
really tastes like. They don't know.
You sorta know swilling your wine,
your mouth. If you've never
really been hammered. Come on son.
He never really been high. Whatever. Do
you eat some dumb stuff? You're hammered,
bro. You like I, I've never
like, I've just like all Jack
in the box. I would never,
I look at Jack in the box, especially
for professional athlete. Right.
I look at that thing like all my God
does that. I'd been drunk before.
Let the best man Jack in a box. It's
just like an orgy of flavors all over.
You just like squirting
mustard all over your,
what's that again?
Let's do it all over your 10
chance slower this time or feeling.
Let me look through it
and I don't think that that's
a healthy diet for anybody.
I think your brain doesn't care.
It's just like, this is what,
at the caveman level, this is
what I need to survive, you know?
And I don't feel like that's
how we should live our lives.
And this is the whole foods.
All you can eat bar a local whole foods.
You just sit there and you play it. You
just picking out of, they have like a,
it's like a salad bar, but whole foods,
yeah,
pay me
skinny fat die of them for sure.
But I could go and get like
unlimited chicken breasts. I'd be on,
I didn't sit right next to the bar.
Well that's what Fogo de Chao is gangster.
That place get mad and cussed out too.
By the way.
I was going to sit on the toilet
custody. I was like, man, Joe Rogan.
I go to child like what
does this way to you?
It's Brazilian hoe depot.
They come on round two like you're
a king with a big lamb shank.
Like would you look some like this
so you of course you'd say yes.
It's meet in your base.
You know what you're going to find out
is they have a mental illness in every
mall too, like fake ones that are just
as good and show shit. The shower.
That was the way it by the pound.
When you,
what you want to eat by the of
the fogo is all you can eat.
Your father said toy. When I
was hurting man, I was like,
I'm going to tweet at Joe Rogan right now.
I feel like when I,
when I eat at that place,
I feel like a real carnivore
because there's nothing
but meat. Yeah. Got to open
up the poop shoot. First name,
asparagus, Broccoli, lettuce,
everything in their pack, the ball or
Greens. Green's a pack your bowl first.
Don't be scared to move them more. We can
eat the meat. Don't do it. Don't do it.
That show we did Brock Lesnar.
You Son Herculite is,
I'm just shit stuck up and y'all
went to Brazil last December.
It's how we ate every day. Yeah,
pretty much. I'm so fat that
you have to training.
Doesn't that feel like the perfect
thing to eat after training?
You ever take a rib bone
and just like just go.
Just to feel like an animal.
I do that with chicken bones.
Bite off the ends and suck the
marrow out of them. Oh Man.
I love your caveman status. I can't
help it. My mom always did it and my,
I grew up with savages, bro. Yeah.
Your mom was picking fleas off the
back of these. She's half Orangutang.
Beautiful, beautiful woman, but brokers,
very shameful that you're swinging
down from the term [inaudible] house.
My mom used to bite the bottoms off
chicken bones and suck the marrow out.
Tell me that sad, some crazy monkey
shit. You know, whatever bro.
Figure that out. You know, we've figured
that out. That's some old world shit.
You know, people stop sucking
marijuana two generations ago,
if it came with food,
became plentiful enough that we didn't
have to suck the marrow out of the bone.
That funny. That's awesome. Do you ever,
you guys ever roll with the kid for him?
I Jerry Maguire.
You remember that little kid,
but I had glasses.
What do you mean do ecstasy with them?
Does Jujitsu and he,
I choked out Heifer on like five times
in a row and he was talking about on his
podcast, how I shamed you wise because
there was a little kid from Jerry Maguire.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I didn't know how friends doing
Jiu Jitsu on a regular basis.
Guess he does it here in there.
Sean Heffron comic,
he won last comic standing.
He's a good buddy of ours.
I did a whole tour with him.
Him and Charlie Murphy lowers the
travel across the country years ago.
I'll look at that. Yeah, we
did a bud light comedy tour.
I could remember that guy's name
so hard. Well, what's he look like?
Heffron and some white guy.
White Guy. Very clean cut.
Very, very funny. Standup comic and a good
dude to party. Yeah, he's a great guy.
But uh,
he likes to go to fucking karate classes
and shit and take new and different
things. You just started wrestling
and does judo and cool. He's cool.
It gets into shit. You know, he's
one of those uh, like real obsessive.
Like one of those guys,
he gets onto something,
it just becomes absolutely
obsessed with it.
For Awhile it was like
that Tony Robbins Shit,
neuro linguistic programming and he
used to like have a little fucking hand
movements.
We going before I went on stage and like
it would do a certain thing with his
hand and that would lock him into the
mindset of him killing when he's on stage
and then he could take it, just
go with it onstage. That's cool.
Amway PR kind of guy.
You believe in that shit.
You've got a lot of interesting
thoughts about motivation and yeah,
I all that
stuff came from um, Milton
Erickson. You know who he is,
know the father of modern hypnosis.
He's really super interesting,
amazing guy who there was one guy
who figured out hypnosis, read, read.
There's three books called
conversations with Milton.
Erickson were giant gringer I think his
names, they come up with it. What year?
Okay. He would be long
passed away no matter what.
What year do you think
they invented hypnosis?
I think versions of it could go on for
someone just kind of put this together.
Okay, so this guy didn't invent
hypnosis. He just says modern.
I think of what people would
know is modern hypnosis.
A lot of it came from Milton
Erickson and he would kind of hit me,
tie this whole groups of people.
Really super interesting guy.
And he was in a wheelchair too? Yes.
You guys got hypnotized before. Wait,
you're talking to this guy
who's a professor at Xavier.
He like in a wheelchair
during this maneuver. Yeah.
That's bad ass like some damn it is.
That NLP stuff came from a lot of
what Milton Erickson was doing.
So he figured out how to,
he was the first guy to figure out
how to hypnotize large groups. Oh,
he would do that just by the way he's
his, the patterns he used to speak. Right,
but did other people just by the pattern,
just so he would go onstage,
he would speak in a certain pattern and
the whole audience would be hypnotized.
Yeah. And then then they, then
he'll cut of drop things into,
he's a really interesting guy. So would
you be hitting it was everybody hit mid?
Does. Who knows if it was
everybody, but that was, yeah,
I remember one guy sent to me,
when you're on stage,
you got to hypnotize the audience
and I've seen you do it. Well you,
what you do is, I wouldn't say
hypnotized. What I say is you,
you get them with your focus and your
intent and with the economy of words so
that you don't,
they don't have to work too hard and know
exactly what you're saying. You, you,
you put g project what you're
thinking into their head.
And then it's like you operate their mind,
they'll allow you inside their mind
to take them on a journey. Yeah.
I wouldn't say it's hypnotizing,
but it is a connection. Right.
There was an undeniable connection that
you have with the crowd. As a comic.
If you, you feel it, you lock into it
and you ride it and you have to ride.
It was like super honesty.
It's like it's a weird thing if you,
if you're not really in the moment it'll,
it'll stop,
it'll stop and then they'll just become
words and you lose this connection.
That's what like Craig report,
all those things go a long way to
keeping that connection going. Yeah.
So this guy just stands or sat there in
the wheelchair and would talk and the
audience would walk out. I would
imagine you have very similar, not like,
like this some up in here.
Make out with the person.
Don't go common consensus.
Yeah, exactly. As he comes.
So there, is there any, I mean,
so you're telling me that people like
I know that people been to the GAM
hypnotizing show and they're
like, yeah, you know,
and maybe she got up and you know,
barked like a dog every
time he snapped his fingers.
And you know any truth to that?
I Dunno. That's what I'm saying.
I'm asking you guys,
I've seen a bunch of times really
comedy comedy shows by a bunch
of different dudes. Yeah, I've seen
it a bunch of times. It's real.
I just doesn't work on everybody.
But it works.
I think you have to have a weekend
mind or are you not necessarily real?
I remember,
remember
this,
what you guys are saying?
I said we were saying that you have to
be a week to get hypnotized to hepatitis
shows. Not necessarily when
I go. So it's been able to,
he was at the funny bone and
then it was this out of nowhere
cause they ever tried to hypnotize,
you know,
I know that's what I'm trying like I
don't think they could do it. I would try.
It would be like, all
right, cool. Let's try.
You have to be willing to let yourself
go. Yeah, it's probably, would it be,
I'll be like, fuck that. Yeah,
you're right. You're right.
I would. I would, you know, you
wouldn't like bark like a dog.
You know what I'm saying?
Like how would you think different
people have different definitions?
First of all, for hypnosis, there's
other people that they would,
they'll describe hypnosis as is just
putting someone in a very relaxed state
where they're receptive to information
and you can talk to them in a more
balanced way. Then you can, when they're
up and hyper at you and looking around.
And so it's the idea of hypnosis.
It's not like they're not conscious.
They are very conscious.
They're conscious and aware.
They're just relaxed into a certain
level of consciousness. It's,
it's not, it's not standard.
It's relaxed and controlled.
And that even though they're
aware of everything, there's
still being hypnotized.
I don't know. I don't, you know,
I don't know what the
official definition of it is,
but I have seen people that are absolutely
hypnotized and believe that there's
things that are going on.
And one of those hypnosis comedy shows,
there's things are going on around them
and they can't control it and they can't
stop it. And they'd come in
their pants. I've seen them.
There's monsters in the room.
I've seen, I've seen all that.
She absolutely hates it.
There's monsters in the room.
There was one where the guy with the
was, there was this guy, Frank Santos,
who had this guy having sex with Madonna
on stage. I'll never forget this.
And the guy's like, and you're inside
of her and you're inside of our,
and the dude just nuts and
his fucking pants. Wait, could
you see the kid just
nuts like immediately,
like knots in his pants and everyone
starts laughing and howling and then you
know the, the Hypno hypnotists goes,
whoa. I guess. I guess you enjoyed that.
All right. All right. Clean
yourself up over there.
And the kid just walks off
stage and they, the, the, the,
the people that worked there helped
him and brought him into the bathroom.
He just fucking shot a load in his
pants. He really believes this,
Brian, or within in the backseat
of my Toyota Prius. Yeah.
I'm not saying it's Michio Kaku
and they're getting hypnotized.
They're probably some knuckleheads,
you know what I'm saying? Is, is like,
what's that guys? This is a plant. No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I know that.
I know the hit mentos the him,
and this was a very honest,
digitally capable of doing it.
Not to everybody.
He would pick people out of the crowd.
He said, who wants to get him to,
he'd bring him up on stage and he
would always know who wasn't really under.
There's some people he goes and
he would tell you, I go, well,
how do you know when they're
not alone? Because I, you
could just tell. I go, well,
what are you doing? He goes, he can't
do it. You can't, can't hypnotize them.
Some people you can't have a
touch. So it's like, there's
almost like some people,
they're programmed in a certain way where
there's just a door open and you can
just open that door and get
inside of newer operating
systems. Yeah. And that was,
that was passed at two points.
Yeah. That's some old shit.
That's Mac Osx or OSPF eight
whatever the fuck it was.
I think everyone has a capability
to go there. Really capability.
If you can relax enough to decide that
that's a place that you're going to go to
your opener. Receptive to it. Of
course. Really everyone. Everyone. Wow.
That's why average. That's things like
advertising works. Does it really work?
I guess it works, right? For
sure, but does it really?
I think what what works more is the
court of public opinion. You know,
like things that are desirable
or desirable because a
bunch of people like them,
not just because of advertisement,
you know, it becomes a chicken.
Egg fell was the last time you saw
Ferrari advertisement. You don't see him.
You know why they don't need to do that
because it's a fucking Ferrari. You know
when you hear that [inaudible] good.
Pretty good.
What are you talking about dude?
They have a Ferrari store in a mall.
You just never leave that.
You could buy their items.
They don't add verdant sizing enough.
Not they're selling things, bro.
Capitalize off their image and making
money. They advertise a different way.
They have a formula one car that's
driven by team Ferrari that's advertised,
but it's also how they
develop their product.
That's why the advertising
works so congruent with their
product. Right. But the,
it's sort of a part of their business.
I wouldn't say it's advertising as much
as I would say it's unnecessary time.
The traditional way I'm putting
an ad in the newspaper. It is,
but what I'm saying is they don't try
to reach outside of their sport and like
make commercials on TV or when was
the last time you saw a commercial for
Ferrari in a magazine? You
know, listen dude, listen,
think about it is that they don't need to,
they're in such an established name.
They do market and advertise that.
Just do it in different ways.
And I feel like he did all the advertising
a long time ago and they did all the
advertisement a long time ago.
There've been,
they'd been such a bad ass me
per sold long that we'd like,
we don't even need to advertise our shit
costs $500,000 and you can't afford it,
so fuck off. You know, like that's really
there. Well, it's not even just that,
it's just that they're the best,
you know, it's like, it's, it's,
it's about Lamborghini.
Why not under gene is,
or they're not as good or something about
them. They're just, it's not the same.
It's like Lamborghini. It's like too
trashy too, you know, trying too hard to,
you know what I'm saying?
I Argo especially,
or it's still pretty wicked.
But if you had to choose between
a Lamborghini and a Ferrari,
like what's a cooler car?
Ferrari's me all day parole. Yeah.
Lab really liked them. Yeah,
because it's like freaking bad
ass when you're a little kid. You were
like, man, I want a Lamborghini Bro.
And have you had a little toy Lamborghini
and you're like, yeah, look at it.
It's purple and black. When it's shiny
or then it gets wet and now it's green.
Hyper Color Lambo. That's what I'm
talking about. So Lamborghini was awesome.
Ferrari was like the old man,
Dork car. When you add a man door,
Jesus buying my like, I have a fuck
James Bond. That wasn't my point.
My point is that I'm just talking
about my matchbox experience, bro.
That's all I'm saying.
Like I just felt like Lamborghini was
really kicking it off and filed circa 1986
don't get me wrong. We're silly
logo, whatever that's called.
That's a pretty fucking Beasley car.
That's a Ferrari. Oh No. Oh yeah.
Marcy Lago. Marciella. Wait,
there's another one that's
the Lamborghini Mercier.
Laga was diverse. She a
logo. Yeah. $350,000 car or
something crazy like that. It's
ridiculous. I just remember that shit
looked like back to the future, bro.
Ridiculous. They're like a super
collagen was. Ferrari is like,
I guess not though for I was
pretty ridiculous. Yeah, exactly.
You see a fiery to know top. If this
looks like a weird, crazy boat car. Yeah,
I know.
It's like,
but love that someone's who's dumb
enough to make something like that.
The dumb enough to make something just,
just fucking completely reckless defies
traffic violations just in first gear.
This is, you know, it'll pass the
fucking speed limit. It's ridiculous. No,
I don't got a driver's license
because I had to call on a car.
It wasn't even that fast.
What happened?
Not just kept getting tickets and throwing
them out the window. Oh Jane. You know,
I just was like, I'll pay it
online. I'll pay it online.
But I didn't realize there was points on
this thing. Like there's a point limit.
I Dunno. I just got that for parking.
You hit the limit and they shut you off.
Yeah, they were like nop. Sorry.
Parking's not that. Right.
Like parking has no points and I
have a bunch of parking tickets too.
I paid them all off though.
I'm a legit,
cause I have a parking ticket
that I don't, can't find
like no, you were speeding.
Yeah a bunch of times. Yeah. And you know,
they just catch you in weird spots like,
like on the way to training and it's just
a back road. There's no school on it.
Or have you ever considered getting
like a real like luxury style car where
you're like a Cadillac or something like
that where you would just drive slow,
like one of those big ass Cadillacs?
Yeah, I'm thinking, I mean,
I know it's like people driving me around,
so glad I lost. Yeah. Like whatever,
just drive me. It's like a
taxed. Just drive me somewhere.
I everybody, I got sarge,
but he went from driving damn land
cruisers on the dam. Afghanistan,
Afghanistan front. Nah, he just drives
me around. I'm like, come on sarge.
Like he was over there and
the sergeants like my homie,
he's like a real close friend of mine and
uh, uh, he got blown up by a rocket man,
Afghanistan, but Nah,
he's good. He's like,
it didn't blow all the way
up and hit his head rest.
He hit his head rest and blasted them
and I just cut into his back and stuff.
He called me up like,
Yo, Bro, I'm coming home.
I forgot to hit by a rocket. I'm like,
for real? I'm like, man, come back dude.
All right, I'll see you. Sooni that all
right, man. He called back two weeks.
I was like, Nah, I'm good bro.
Fuck that. I've killed all
these guys. I'm like, oh my,
like, all right, what can you say to
that? Right. Uh, I understand. Uh,
fucking go for it. Like, Yo, but
he made it back, dude. And I,
and we went and visited.
What was this about?
What the fuck did this conversation get
started? Fine. I don't care. I, I did.
Now I'm talking about it, so I'm
excited. It's not, oh, oh, because sarge
sarge get into this for driving you
around. Oh, hey. Drive me around. Yeah,
that's the whole point I was making
anyway, but yeah, but, but I'm saying he,
that's the craziest story, Dude. And
that's what's happening to kids in a,
you know, kids like this guy was like
23 years old. Like, I'm like, Damn Dude.
Like he's been through enough adventure
for a man three times his age,
you know, already. I didn't
mean to get it, y'all.
I just got me started cranking
about sarge. Sorry guys.
You him being kicked out
of more commentary by Jason
May, Him Miller. No, I know,
but I'm just thinking cause
you know I could've done it.
I joined up real easy because my old man
was any and like I grew up in the army,
you know,
so so I like,
I feel like real connection to to the
dude's and army and I'm like that we're in
in the marines and air force,
whatever. I'm just like,
I see how you've got to live to be in
that you should be able to do whatever the
fuck you want to do in this life.
But it is kind of weird when you see
those crazy video game commercials about
joining the Marines. But why when you
go wow, that's like really shit up.
Or the video games that they make,
that's like call of duty but they make it,
they have an army gain really game day.
What is his call of duty based in the
present time or is it a call of duty is
awesome. It's going to be cranking
on, I don't know anything about it.
Some of them are road warriors.
One something like a roid Tucson's
Vietnam of the latest ones.
Our modern warfare might feel
like you're in a real war.
Who plays in that shit is Bruce buffer.
We were in England and this
dude was in his laptop,
his laptop on with fucking crazy eyes
really online jack and people looking
through windows and throwing
grenades and shit. I was like,
what is that call of duty?
It's ridiculous.
It's the graphics and
everything, but man, I,
you see people how fucking tuned in.
They get to these game course video
games that hardcore for a long time.
But my point is when is the next
level of immersion gonna Come?
Cause you know it's gonna.
They're gonna figure out some
fucking anywhere already.
Did they have those rappin led goggles?
You're going to be able to
look down and see your feet.
You're going to be able to look around.
You're going to be in that fucking world,
man, that's around the
corner. That's a decade away.
They're going to figure out some fucking,
some virtual reality shed
because when we were a kids,
virtual reality was what they
kept talking about. It's coming,
wait until virtual reality. But
then when it came, it was like this,
just like goggles and it looks
whack. Yeah, but technology
is advancing now. Yeah,
exactly. They stepped up their dick
like they don't like running so fast.
I stepped on their Dick like
now it's the shits common and have
to figure out how you move around.
How would you move? You know,
because you'd want to move.
Your body can't move your body
and let's we should sensors.
Could do is have people
in giant warehouses,
hollow deck them.
Give them the virtual reality experience.
You'd put the fucking helmet on them
and set them in the center of a giant
warehouse and the warehouse
as they walked around.
When you never watched star trek, Bro,
you never want to star trek before.
Different than the Holodeck. The
holodeck, the Holodeck. You're like,
I'm going up to the Holodeck it.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Are you saying star trek as
in the next generation? Of
course. Come on. Then worse.
I didn't wash that fuck. Out of respect,
out of respect to get the Kirk, whatever.
I was a great show. You're missing.
I was too young for that shit. Okay,
so spect. That was by
version. Okay. And I'll care.
Broker wharf is a bad motherfucker.
Okay. I'll just tell you right now data.
He was awesome. He's super
smart. Sometimes he had
emotions, sometimes he didn't,
you know. And you know, after like star
Trek, the next generation gets overlooked.
I can't do it. Satta yeah, they
should have Scotty. Scotty again.
He was like 900 years old.
Had a mustache.
A funny fucking boys head was gigantic
and watermelon. Like no need for that.
Do you see the Michael
Jackson death photo? Oh Wow.
What they believe is Michael
Jackson's death. Well,
I mean they did had in court
that was the courtroom pitcher.
But is it really because it's on Kinsey
and that's happening. They got it from,
they said,
well someone was in court and the
prosecutors were showing it to show that
because I think the opening statements
broadcast live on TMZ right now. Whoa.
Can you stream? Actually it
hasn't. How crazy is that?
He is a legitimate news source
in a fucking courthouse. Well,
Michael Jackson's, it's just public.
I think it's open to talk about,
that's the perfect place to put that.
There it is.
It's like that's the celebrity
worship Shit, you know? That's weird.
This Michael Jackson Dr Thing. It's
kind of funny man. Yeah. What happened?
I don't even know what happened.
Did he killed the guy or was was,
I just can't wait for the,
the def photo music video that were,
they used that photo to do music,
you know, Shit like that. It's coming
and I did
both of you guys get a fucking real
stop.
Hey Joe Rogan.
So loud is a radio show.
He's supposed to be like, no,
this is not a radio show.
This is a conversation amongst friends.
Why you talking to me in a way you
would never talk to him on the Internet.
You wouldn't be doing this
smelly took it to another level
because when the internet,
you took it to another level.
You Ain't help me.
Do I not fucking flip out like that
on a normal basis, I can't help it.
Do you think, why do you think I go to a
gym everyday guys? Because that's your,
that's my job.
But guess what?
It stopped me from having
jobs where I had to be normal.
I can run around on the mat and go,
fuck the shit out of me sometimes.
So,
so I'm just saying I picked that path
to your medication. Your, there you go.
So I would just want to yell some time
clip ons, I think to my wiener dog, Bro.
Do you monster fuck bitches stewed.
He's gone to, it's up to him.
Why do you want to watch me? No,
I mean I can just imagine you
make a left turn thing two. Neither
admit to or even acknowledge. I know.
Why is he, what do you want
it? You want to watch of that?
And then you want to wrestle
in the corner crying.
What? You fucking some girl
weeping as it comes to just dribbles
on his foot. Whoa, Whoa, Whoa,
whoa.
Oh my God.
Hey Gavin, drinks of coffee guys. What
do you think? That's a good idea for sure
need in your life? Um, when you,
um, when you, uh, start, uh, uh,
training for your training for you.
December 3rd fight already,
but you have to wash it like coffee. Do
you, do you limit that for you? Not now.
Coffee, not so much, but man,
I stopped chewing tobacco.
Man. It was making me angry.
I like, I have to stop now. I just
stopped. You were doing it in Colorado,
were you in when we were up there
and you stay it? I just quit. Yeah.
I was like man, you know
what? This is stupid.
My doctor coffees that he's got to stop
that. I was like, all right, I'll stop.
It's not even that hard. It's just you
get the coffee. I stopped drinking coffee,
it's fine.
But I stopped.
I stopped in coffee before
I had a headache after
three days, man. That right.
And then,
but uh,
but this thing is just a man I want
to choose and then I'm going to not,
I don't know. I don't know.
I know. And then that's it.
There's no like pain or anything. What is
it you do for you? It does it like hey,
time's up your brain.
That's for sure. Yeah.
That's why I could see why
people smoke cigarettes. Cause I,
you know the nicotine is kind of like uh,
the same,
same concept that neuro Noah
tropic, right. You want to,
your brain comes alive a little
bit and you've kept focused down.
But I don't know man.
No
nicotine in general has that sort of a
to me, to me it's more of like a calming,
relaxing,
but it's in more of a check.
Like he's right and they can
kind of gives you a check.
Kevin James loves cigars and
smoke cigars together. You know,
it's one of the rare times I smuggled.
But you get high off of those things.
You Do, you get some weird buzz off
a good cigar for sure. It's nice.
It's nicotine is a drug nicotine
but I don't get addicted.
I don't like need it the next day.
When you started the chipper takes a
long time to get addicted though. Yeah.
And it's a different type of
high anyway. Yes. Smoking is,
the guard is like intense burning in
your mouth and you feel the nicotine like
quick burn that but doing
that God dip or whatever.
Like it's like more like a constant thing.
You know what I mean? Like a constant,
not that intense or constant,
you know,
so I can see why people get addicted
to and whatever. But you know,
now upon my memory,
I
thought it was like 18 months or two,
three years to get addicted to cigarettes,
no route 18 miles.
It takes 18 months to get a real physical
addiction because I don't know how to
help them remember that Ryan would
be able to tell you about it.
That's what that's about,
right?
I mean I think like the first c I'm
fortunate I started when I was 15 and I
think the first couple of years it was
more of just like I was smoking because I
was in high school and me and my friend
would go to his house during lunch break
and just smoke cigarettes. But it wasn't
like I needed to smoke cigarettes,
but it was kind of like we just did it
cause we were in high school. Surprise.
I thought what happened real quick, but
it doesn't. Oh that's crazy. Well good.
I I missed the window.
I did that for a little while.
We still have that time
when I was in high school,
the baddest kid on the wrestling
team smoked cigarettes.
Just try to kid mark calling.
He was sick wrestler it's fucking wiring
and just run forever. Who
smokes cigarettes? Just
rotten 12 miles. I'm like,
what the Hell is fucking cigarettes?
We worked out in the basement,
that's where the, the wrestling room
was all fucking as best as in there.
But he's probably out of that shit.
All the insulation was all it's,
you know,
1981 or whatever the fuck it was and
mark would wrestle and then he would go
outside and smoke a cigarette and the
snow standing there and it's fucking a
wrestling all sweaty and shit. Smoking
a cigarette. His girlfriend, this snow.
I was like,
what a crazy asshole.
But he was just such a wild
mother fucker when he wrestled.
That kid could have been, he could have
been a legit killer wrestler, but just,
you know, everybody's met guys like
that where they just, you know,
they just have a few vices that they
can never let go and get a taste for it.
I want to hang out in the snow and they
take it to a high level but they can't
keep going. They get to a real high level
and they just sort of like flat line,
you know, they don't keep
continuing and that upward path,
that's the most difficult dance is to
maintain your balance to the entire
progression. You know, as a, as a fighter,
it's probably not and did not as a
fighter through life [inaudible] life for
sure.
You know,
it's this excelerate this accelerated
view of what happens in life and anything
like anything that does it very,
very difficult.
I would think about
that as like fights as,
as poetry for the actual act of
living life. You know what I mean?
If you look at each individual
fight, they, it has a story.
If you break it down frame by frame,
you know, and you do your job.
If you really think about it,
like a lot of it is are we get so
used to it and desensitized to it,
but every bite has like
a little story in it.
You know that that's what makes
the big smarter. The Lord.
Like really interesting to me. Like,
like, because everything you do,
your life to play can play out in just
this exact particular way as a fight.
You know what I mean?
Like they mirror each other and shit
can happen and should happen. Do you,
do you look at your career like your, your
future ahead and saying, you know, hey,
you know, this is when I'm going
to get out. I have, you know,
x amount of years before shit starts to
get slippery and then we'll talk about
this before. Like, I feel like, yeah, you
know, at some point your body goes like,
you gotta go okay. And look at
it from, you know, I don't know.
You have to take that as a fighter.
You have to take that from every angle,
you know what I mean? And, uh, see what's
best for you. You know, there's guys that,
you know, plenty guts, nobody goes
out on top, you know what I mean?
You got Pornstar career coming up. You
have to, you know there's some guys,
I don't know.
It's just what can you do in the time
that you have to do with it and if not
fucking know. You know? What are we
trying to, you map it out. Mary Bridge.
Do you write down like the things that
you want to do? Yeah, I, yeah, I do. Yeah.
This is getting kind of weird. I
feel personal. It feels personal.
It's personal for me too.
I've come over to my house and I have my
like motivation things on the wall and
I get fucking embarrassed because
people read them. I know a clown or you.
Yeah, exactly. One of them was super
embarrassing singles fucking chicken. One,
I want to get my asshole bleach in.
My little things that I wrote down is
be someone that you would be envious of.
My God, what did I do? She fucking
thing too. It's a good idea.
It just good life by that. It is good, but
you have to, most people don't do this,
but you have to set out to become an
interesting person because no one's born
that way. You have to do
things in your life to make.
I think there are people that
are absolutely interesting
without even trying,
you know? They just, just,
just think a certain way and they have
certain interests and certain desires.
I don't think you have to
set out somewhere. They start
venturing down that trail,
dig AWS just because that's what the
w what fascinated them. You know?
But then you guys are chicken and egg
right now. You guys always do that.
That's pretty interesting.
But if he can't,
I think wild statements like
no one ever blank. You know?
For sure someone can be
interesting without trying.
I know a lot of people that are just
probably autistic and it just genius.
It's an absolutely fascinating and
they're not trying at all. You know?
I know like video game coders. Do you
ever talk to like one of those head guys?
One of those fucking, some guys just
hit the lottery and are interesting.
Naturally. He bullied. Just fascinating.
They're just fascinating
people without trying at all.
I feel like everybody got a story.
Everybody. Some people have no story.
Some people got shit dig hole than die.
Well,
that's a story in itself and there
could be some beauty in there.
Sort of one of those little stories.
That's a coming of age story.
It's a coming of age
and a Jack in the box.
Remember you get a little story
book and the Jack in the box.
That's that guy's life.
I couldn't afford Jack in the box.
You couldn't afford a jacket, not
jacket. I live this a cracker.
Donald's like,
what's a whole different thing?
The little toys that you got,
and I said,
Jack in the box to the crack and they
have the little tattoos. I'm like,
you know what I mean, but
whatever. You know what it was.
You were talking about how delicious
checking the boxes. I totally
out of kickbox and if you
don't master Todd again, sure.
That guy is an interesting,
interesting Carrie.
You would tell me when we were at that,
a professional lawyer,
all the pads for me and I'm like, alright,
mean. He's like, no, no, no. Look,
the pods don't look at the pads pads.
I'm like,
okay, I won't look at the pact.
Oh look, my eyes, my eyes,
he both ties to my eyes, my
eyes. That's what he'd say.
What you hid paths with them then? I
had a look of it. The ice, you know ty,
you try not the lab.
Yes.
Edd.
Explain that for people that don't know,
that's fucking to why crew,
you have to do this dance before you go
into the ring and he wanted to do the
dance and it's like, you
know, I mean it's cool,
but explain the music while the
fights going on. In this case,
three minute rounds. Okay. The
whole time it's like, it's like uh,
the cafe scene from star wars music.
Sure. It's very weird interest.
The big a girl dancing with blue hair.
I mean blue like tubes coming out of
her head. We could, we could play.
What is the real you? Yeah. What is
it called? Put a why crew with w y u.
K are you U or a why crew?
Why crew type music?
You can put what type music American
because Sarge sarge before we battle that
call of duty. Yeah. He puts the
point time music and it does the dam.
That's the wide crew. No joke, Bryan.
He's like, God does the little dance,
but I'm going to kill you. I'm
like, really? Did where are you?
He does have a free train.
No, but yeah, no, no, no, no.
I'm fucking douchebag guys.
Got a fucking,
where are you training?
Who are you training with?
Martyna. [inaudible]. Cordero.
Yeah. No Dora. Yeah, what an honor that
is, Huh? Yeah. Training with the manager.
Fucking shoot the bucks if we have
a crazy team right now. So people,
when people don't know is this sound when
you're watching Moitai they, this is,
this is played through the entire fight.
It's fucking awesome. Exactly the song.
But he had a tape. He had a
tape, not a bug of the CD.
A tape of this music playing three minutes
and then in the middle of the rounds,
you know the one minute rest period was,
wow,
I like that. How are you doing? Put that
music on it a little bit in the boat.
Put on his dope. I want to dance. I
used to not like it when I was younger.
I was still like, this is gross. Why
don't they have to play this music?
But now as I've gotten older and
embraced differences and cultures,
I find it fascinating. I love
the dance like this. I like it.
I don't know what that world boy type
thing we saw I think was awesome.
It was awesome. The first
batch I was like, oh,
I'm not used to this now it might a
second match. Third match. I was like,
this is great. Loved it. Yeah. Especially,
you know the grill high level stuff,
crazy stuff that happened.
The elbow crazy elbows.
This guy's caught each other
with and stuff like it was great.
We saw a book called POW Promac.
I think that's how you say his name.
We saw him get his 198th win.
Yeah,
so relaxed. He was like
a vent. Massive road.
He's so good and he's not even 30 or he's
just turning 30 or something like that.
If I've been pro for 17 you're
God damn right. Mantled homeboy.
He dismantled home boy
and he did it so relaxed.
It was like this guy never had the
chance. It was all technique. Yeah,
like everything he did, he was always
in the right place. Yeah. It's neat.
Samos kicks. He beat that. He fought that
whole fight with the knees basically.
Yeah cause he just came out with
like dieting on me every and it
actually in a second,
a third round,
he started doing that because now he
found that was this point where you hit
away. But he also did a lot of
like outside kicks and and hooks.
It was all landed lack Odey
he kicked that guy's arms.
Oh yeah. Oh that he was
so relaxed. He's like,
then when he fight fight you
could see it like he's so chill.
How about in like the fourth round when
he put his hand up and walked away from
the dude? Yeah, he put his arm
on. Who should I take him now?
Like chained to the audience and like
looks at the audience telling him about
his white crew was awesome shit
to like stop it on the ground.
Like that really happened was the guy who,
the other guy,
I believe he's from Canada, I'm
not sure, I don't know Canada,
but that might be wrong.
Wherever we got Africa,
the other guy apparently pushed him at
the Wayans and got in his face and said a
bunch of crazy shed and so book house
that he was going to punish him and he
told everyone going.
So he did his why crew like like
pretending was shooting arrows.
So he's doing his little pre-fight
dances stomps on the game and it's like
shooting arrows at the guy and he got
like in the guys' space like wait too
close.
Whereas first fist was like,
like literally inches from
the guys face when he ended.
So it was really like intense.
And then he went out there and
just dismantled to do slowly.
That guy had some flashes of
greatness hands he can punch.
It was really good and he came straight
a few times and landed and came with a
straight and hook combination.
You see the experience of book,
how would fade back when the dude was
attacking that was coming after him and
punches. He would just fade back and
then needs fade back and the knees,
time up, Bang needs the body needs
the buddies like flippy knees,
where's his fucking hip turns and just
digs his knee to the side of your rib
cage and the Torque in the fucking
technique that that guy has, man.
And then he just started
chopping homeboys leg,
you know that weird tie sort of dance.
And they don't watch that though.
It's crazy. With the style kickboxing,
you can get so much more loose.
Been in mixed martial arts. You don't
have to worry about getting taken down.
So it's kind of funny isn't it?
That like to really see the highest
level of striking. Here's the rules.
Just kicking. Yeah. But you know,
I mean that makes sense that there's
going to be a hybrid. You know,
we're seeing it now. The hybrid is, is
bound to happen in mixed martial arts.
Do you think that for a young
fighter who's developing, it's,
it's important to have like just straight
grappling matches and just straight
kickboxing matches, well not
ranked. That helps you at all?
I think it helps a little bit,
but I don't think,
I think you definitely need
to mix up because that's what,
that's what's happening,
you know?
And the real benefit is learning
how to compete. It takes a long,
just like you'd doing standup,
I'm sure took a long time to
get comfortable or Jason Fight,
whatever it is that you specialize in,
you have to put hours in.
It's tough if you're doing
striking because maybe you're
getting hit in the head
for hours.
Grappling tends to be easier and that's,
and if you were competing every day,
it would be so much easier.
Of course your body wouldn't
be able to withstand it,
but mentally it would be so much easier
than if you're competing once every six
to nine months. That becomes like a real
enough to really get you going. Yeah,
well don't,
most fighters
have their best fights when they have a
fight and then a short layoff and then
another fight.
It's like you barely break camp,
you relax a little bit and then boom,
you already conditioned did
you don't have that backend.
Being consistent as a fighter is like
one of the most important things.
If he's just like consistently training,
we'd never really fall off.
You get back in the room,
hey your and your work on things and you
actually have a roadmap to go somewhere
at the end of this little special set
of kept like, I lifted weights one time.
Like, all right, this
is what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna get stronger during this
part of my camp. You know what I mean?
And then Ryan has me do so.
All right,
we're going to work exclusively on does
grounded pound. You know what I mean?
Like just focus on that thing,
you know?
It really keeps your mind in tune and
learning new stuff. You know what I mean?
Like it's not like just
putting in the grind hours.
I remember I'd been with camps before
where you just fight. Just fight. Yeah.
We talked about this when we were out to
dinner the other night in Colorado and
Utah. Yeah, yeah. When you
first started training with Dan,
Dan Henderson just fought every day.
I was like in a high school gym and I was
like, all right, let's fight. Oh, cool.
Yeah. I first, I was nervous to go
turn it down. Like, man, this, I dunno,
this would be stupid man.
I showed up to the dam wrestling room at
some podunk high school and I was like,
and he was like, Oh, put yourself
on, we're going to fight. I kinda,
you know, I was like, all right, that's
fine. You said we're going to fight that.
Basically I was, I didn't say we're
going to spar. Uh, you know, and it was,
that was the, didn't matter. Let's
fight. Let's let them call it spark bro.
And I was so happy at that
time of my life. I was like,
ah, yeah, good. No pressure.
Just fucking know. Like,
uh, like some, uh, some,
some trainer with a big ass
ego. Just, just a dude like,
and another dude fighting and in some
of the guys fighting. Yeah, but did it,
how'd you guys work on technique?
Drilled a little bit,
but it was basically like fighting too.
There's never a whole lot that had so
much fun. Let's fight. Let's fight. Yeah.
Yeah. It was just so fun, man. It's got
to be some serious life experience though,
as far as like for just the
rest of your whole MMA career,
the amount of rounds you put in with that
fucking savage swinging at you and IGA
bunch. Hardest Shit you got to watch out
for it. His right here. Yeah. Fuck yeah.
You do.
Right hands ridiculous.
That upper cut that he cut fade or with
that under upper called that was just
like, ah Ha. You didn't know that was
coming and it was hard as fuck dude.
That angle it out. It was the
perfect, yeah, that was a perfect,
perfect placement man. He's just so
confident in that fucking right hand.
We were talking about this before
we started doing this podcast.
He's just re re reached some new level man
on a bungalow. Yeah, great bump. Listen,
there's, there's no secrets anymore
here. I'm going to show you.
I'm going to do and then
I'm going to do it. Yeah.
You know you got moved to so good
that you, that it works on everybody.
You're going to do it.
Sure. Yeah. There's guys,
I mean look at Cody Mckenzie and
he's fucking good team. You know,
we might never be able
to beat elite level guys,
but that guy catches his fucking
arm underneath your chin.
He's put 11 dudes out with
that shit and he catches guys.
Man got a weird crazy good team where
it goes under it and then he squeezes it
and turns it up and press is against
it like this and just fucks you up man.
And he's got that shit down laser tight.
It's funny when a guy's got like one
move like that and just just can lock his
shit up on you.
You know like who some are Paul
Harris and his fucking heel hooks.
You didn't think his heel hooks to
that devastating. You rolling them.
Wrestle with them.
An arm bar rustling.
I thought I was really wary
of that. I was like, Oh,
here comes one of those crazy things and
I jumped off the way. Like I was like,
I knew real good foot lock stuff.
Yeah. I'm real good at that.
I didn't think about it.
Yeah.
And I'm flexible so you've got to catch
me just right. You know what I mean?
You can't, it's, it's rough to get is
going after those fucking things. You,
you probably just wouldn't tap.
That would be your problem.
You'd get ripped apart again. Maybe you
did with chocolate. Yeah, maybe. Yeah.
Jquery. I remember watching that
scrunching up while you were not tapping.
I was watching on TV going, I didn't
even feel any pain. I was like,
what are you doing? I was like, Oh me,
me tore your ACL would
pop it out right there.
It was crazy. But you know, I
in the moment you don't care.
You just like you're do anything
like I, you know, I feel like man,
it'd be no prob like you'll have
to carry me out of there. Like,
I'm not stopping no matter what.
Like no matter what,
I'm just going to keep fighting and
keep fighting. If you got Tim Sylvia,
what if you like when he fought Frank
Mir and is a forum snapped the owl fight?
Of course, of course. Really
whatever. Just keep fighting.
I broke my thumb before like and cat it.
Turn it around backwards
and kept fighting. Yeah,
I smashed my hands and just
keep punching with the fee.
Worry about if something like that Tim
Silvia thing happened and you got kicked
out and again,
that might be,
or my arm might even have to be answered
at the time. You might not care about.
What do you mean? All you're thinking
about is just when the fight,
no matter what, he's just picking that
just win the fight no matter what.
If you catch on fire in the octagon,
just keep fighting until you're nothing.
That's the only way to do so.
We've had these talks before you
made a meal inside turns, right?
If I'm getting killed in there,
you better throw the towel in.
But say that it's your responsibility
because I won't, I won't even care.
I'm not going to care. It's your job to
make sure I don't die cause I don't care.
And then I got it CR. If I ended up, if
I end up retard, he's going to kill me.
Like if I break my neck or something
and I'm like, because like I said, man,
just come to shoot me to put me in a but
of bullying in my head. Why would you,
what if the shot you and then a week
later they figured out some new jobs.
I'm not 100% want to be a vegetable bro.
I don't want them to remember me as
maybe just for a week and they'd be
vegetable [inaudible] happened nude.
Like maybe you'd be a
vegetable for a year.
Would you be willing to be a face to me
for a year if they could figure out like
look at Jason, I know you're in there,
but one in in one week guaranteed.
How are you going to guarantee, oh,
stem cell research rejuvenation.
They going to just put a needle in
your spine injected with stem cells.
Avatar tree. Yeah, but I would love
that and then I changed my mind.
I changed my mind.
If I can plug my ponytail and be your
butt every come to you I want to do,
that would be dope. I would say I
would take that. Could you imagine?
You could find out if people are
completely full of Shit or not?
The first time you fucked him,
that would be a man.
That's the Cheetah avatar living.
Yeah, I know. Oh Shit. This hose dirty.
I connected the speech.
You never been to France.
Crazy lion asshole.
All right man. Let me
sit up. Sit down, buddy.
I guess got amped right now. Sorry guys.
That's what you do. That's where you are.
That's why you you, there's nothing wrong
with being crazy and having bursts it.
Just try to manage it. Do your best
and these years are just these,
the way you just ask me, you have these,
my sunglasses or Joe Rogan said yes,
I'll take that as a compliment
because they're mine. Well,
I've done it as a compliment that
you would take that as a compliment.
That they look good on
you. Thanks man. Um,
so anyway, we're, we're
talking about rocket ships. No,
we're talking about you dealing with fame.
How are you dealing with,
it's weird for sure. It was a bully beat
down the big step. The first big step.
Yeah. But now, you know, being
back, damn ultimate fighters status.
Did you feel any different thing man?
Cause uh,
cause the people at the UFC fans are like,
like man,
they're excited fans all over the,
all over the country. They're excited,
they're super excited and up in your face.
It's great.
Like it's a whole different realm. But
I've gone to now, so like I'm like,
oh okay cause the bully beatdown people,
there are people who watch TV.
These are people that watch fights.
Right. So there, you know, on, I dunno,
it's really interesting to see every, and
I love everybody, you know, it's crazy.
And the UFC got me to sign autographs
and stuff and I'm doing that. Um,
what do you call that? A,
the fan expo and Houston.
You doing good to like connect with people
who love mixed martial arts, you know?
And I'm like, I'm like,
yeah, it's cool. You know?
It's definitely a different world
though too, that's for sure. And,
and being famous, you know, there's
was some drama. Well you got,
you got slowly famous though.
Right?
Did you feel a bump when you started
fighting on CBS when you like when you
fought Jake shields? There's any bump
from that. Yeah, of course. Yeah.
That was like a million people
watched it and a lot of people,
what is it like a million?
How many people watched that on
CBS with a Bra Bra brawl thing? Oh,
that thing's been on the Internet.
Everybody knows what that was good for
you in the long run. In the long run,
it was defeated. Everybody
hates me. I'm like, yeah, but
it wasn't even, I was like,
you it to be like,
I hadn't tried to be like,
I wish I could have been
in on those meetings.
I would have straighten those bitches
out right away. I swear to God,
I would've sat all those fucks coker and
all those dummies down. I don't. I said,
listen, why the fuck did he get
in the octagon in the first place?
Why are you not on the door?
Why do you have so many people?
And if you're going to have a guy
come in and talk shit, the other guy,
how about you let the other guy
have his fucking speech first?
And you did inform him that he's
going to be talking to this other guy
afterwards. And this is just marketing
and trying to set up a fight,
but they just didn't
have control of the cage.
And then all of a sudden this one guy
gets jumped by a bunch of fucking wild
dogs and it's your fault.
This is ridiculous. It's
completely, totally ridiculous.
The most one sided perspective
that they had just chosen.
Mauro looked at you that that famous
picture that you're talking about,
he's giving you the stink guys.
You walking by with a grin on your face
in front of Gus Johnson while they're
reapplying is makeup and
you're walking by and the
best picture ever. So it's happened
and explained my whole life bars,
like tighten up a suit, like may
have Miller shame on you. Mayhem.
I who got that picture there? I'll tell
you what, man. I've gotten to know Mauro.
I like moral Rinaldo. I hung out with
him at the Moitai professionally thing.
When he was done, he kept talking to me
all, you know, they call me moral water.
That's what they call me.
Marajuana so we're going to get high.
I'm gonna get high with marijuana
and we're going to have a good time.
I liked that dude though. He grew on me.
Moral Rinell grew on me. That was great.
He's a fungus. The fungus. No,
I liked the guy. He's funny.
He's funny, but he's, he's
always been real cool man. I had,
I had a beef with them a couple of
times and I feel good with them. Well,
you have to be. I had to go, hey dude. And
then he, he responded. I was like, okay,
I can respect that. I'd see his
perspective and he see my perspective.
He doesn't very,
very broad.
Very rarely does he ever
say anything negative about
fighters. I appreciate that.
I appreciate that because they,
you know,
there's a lot of people out there that
think that the way to get attention or
the way to,
you know,
the way to be snarky is to criticize
fighters and they do it not, you know.
Yeah. I was 60 years old.
Rock kick your ass fires that,
that was the funniest shit ever
be back pedal like the next day.
He didn't need debt back
pulled immediately when
he came down and talked in
front of them.
By the way,
I don't believe really that if I was 50
years old I could kick his ass and he
was laughing.
I actually respected him for that.
It was kind of funny because
it was so ridiculous,
but to come down and ground
and pound and you'd never know.
Never know what if he was like neo Gracie.
Even at that age, she has a clinch.
He gets the clean and the trip. Now
you were in my world, the ground,
he's the ocean and I am a shark
and most people cannot swim.
Very merchant back to you.
Imagine if langue, immersion,
just fucking but just fucking arm drag
them and took us back fucking rear naked
choke on them for you. I'll just rolled
forward with the hooks in stretches him.
Now what the fuck goes out?
Both his own jacket and repel heels,
Jacqueline Marcello Garcia
is that bitch can make,
whether it be at one boxing glove,
there's a dude on the underground
that's going to close that.
Yeah. There's nothing like, you know,
the underground is awesome
for good and for bad.
There's a line of fucking assholes
and angry people and insulting people.
But this is a lot of fucking cool people.
That's one of the most unusual sites.
And I think a big part of,
one of the reasons why it's so cool
is a huge percentage of the people
on that site train. You know,
on the underground, I would say like
30 or 40 a lot of old school people,
a lot fucking noobs.
But I remember the submission fighting.co
I remember that too. Yeah. Right.
And it became [inaudible] dot TV and
then it became mixed martial arts to,
I remember I lost it for a while. Then
it came back. Yeah. I was like, oh,
this is the, what year did it
start? You got to be on, no man.
I'm starting to like 94
or five I was at AOL.
I was a member back when I was on the
old UFC when I worked for the old UFC,
so that was like 97 or
98 I became a member
because it was back in the day like that
was crazy cause that's a crazy way to
have a sport like thrive.
You know what I mean?
They connected on the Internet and back
then those were the dark times that at a
certain point there was no MMA on TV
at all. It was all a satellite dish.
That's why I got a satellite dish because
that's the only way you could watch
the UFC and he can watch the pride.
Then all of a sudden pride was on to it.
I was like, oh, there's another choice.
Occasionally you'd have some weird fight
that you could buy on pay per view like
Hicks and Gracie versus Funai or
something like that. It was, you know,
coliseum MMA. You know, some new Danny
can old thing, but it was old at the time.
This is done well.
There's not many,
there's not many like startup shows
ever again on paper view. Right.
Like the shark fights that's on,
is that paper view or is that each senior
interview? It was, I think it's HD net.
Now the ANC they did a paper view.
They did a pay per view.
I think it's fucking hard to
sell a pay per view, you know?
I mean did he get a lot of people
knowing about it? That's for sure.
I know fade or had one paper
view that did like miserable,
like 10,000 fucking buys. I think
pride ever digital? Well either. No.
In the United States I don't think so
because we've got the gardener or a pay
per view event. No they're not. I mean
if it's nothing, it's just like click,
you know,
you want to garner hype for like a UFC
couldn't do it unless they were tight
like created to,
you really want to watch this.
I want to pay the $50 the same
thing with boxing the UFC.
So super smart for putting as much shit
on TV and regular TV as they can versus
end spike TV and now fox and FX. The
ultimate fighter is going to be on FX now,
which is going to be fucking huge
fights on Fox or cause on that channel.
Louis. Well, everything's
good. That's a good channel.
Even though they go all
the way back to the shield,
you know that was a three or
four shows from that for sure.
Four different theories on that same
channel. It's weird. Avexis Badass.
So we're going to have having
the ultimate fighter on Fx,
they're going to revamp it to,
they're going to figure out some new
things and they're even going to do some
live events live on TV, like actual
fights. So it's going to be crazy.
Fighters can be live next year, right?
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about. Fx.
I think it's a fantastic idea. Fucking
great idea. It's going to be wicked.
It's going to be a wicked show that we
change the whole experience of it. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Well knowing
that a million people are
going to watch it. Yeah.
Then the pressure's going to be
different and it's going to be creepy.
1 million people watching it live as it
plays off, but in there, what do you hear?
You hear just 10 people yelling, 20
people yelling. It's awesome. Yeah.
That's going to be,
that's going to be bad ass.
So only the fights will be live and
the rest of the show we'll be like,
what's building up to this day?
It'd be like 24 seven in that
they claim I'm pretty bad at.
They're going to have a,
you know,
the storyline will play out
and then you know the people,
we'll be warming up waiting for
the storyline to end and boom,
we go right into the fight. Crazy.
Yeah. That's fans who fights?
Is that the question? I
Dunno. That's a good question.
I don't think that's a good idea though.
I like the idea of strategy picking.
You know it's, it's important, you
know, don't you think the show? Yeah.
I feel like dirt,
my experience in it and people are gonna
Watch it damn on spike, right? Yeah.
Is that,
yeah,
the bill fight picker and go strategy of
it is a big like cool part of the show.
I think fans should be able to vote what
they think is going to happen. You know,
like vote, who he thinks is going to
win and we got damn it wiped up. Fuck.
Can't they bet on it.
You know that makes me sick.
Nanny state little bitch ass government.
We have,
you should be able to
bet on that everywhere.
When you go to the God damn corner
and you buy lottery tickets,
you should be able to bet on
Henderson versus shogun. You know,
I'll take 50 bucks on Henderson, you know,
come on. You should be able to do that.
And why can't you do that? Why
can't you do that? Texting wrong,
but from their own impulses and and all
the rest of us who can deal with it.
Oh yeah,
you're a Social Darwin Day.
Fuck you gotta go to fucking Vegas
to place a bet. That's ridiculous.
I should be able to bet everywhere.
She'd be able to have bedding places as
long as they're legitimate and they pay
their taxes, you know, Jesus Christ.
But what sports betting Slagle here,
that dump people are just going to blow
all their money being on the street.
There's a lot of that people protest
against any vices pre people protest
against any, anything that's templating
or that it's tempting. You know, they,
they protest against trip
clubs for the same reason.
They don't want vice near them.
They want temptation, you know,
for people that can fucking handle it and
enjoy it. It's a real pain in the ass,
man.
It's a real pain in the ass.
You can't just bet on fights because
it makes it much more interesting.
Even when you're with your friends, like
if you watch fights with your buddies,
do you ever bet like,
I'll bet fuck off five bucks on this dude.
Even if you don't even know him,
he will like watching a tough
enough or something like that. Yeah.
I'll take five bucks in the skinny
white dude. Let's do it. You know,
you did make some more
exciting. It does, right? Yes.
Why the fuck isn't that illegal? Uh,
that drives is not, there's a lot of,
there's a lot of dumb people who had
just spent all that money and that you
could trick the dump people into
giving you all their money. I'm,
I'm 44 years old and as I get older I
start thinking I am probably going to
eventually expire and none of
this shit will have changed.
It'd be just as ridiculous. It was when
I was seven when I was a little boy.
It's just as fucking stupid.
I don't know if it is what is involved in
three different fucking wars right now.
The economy is based on unfixable bullshit
that nobody understands the fucking,
the, the, the, the whole idea
of what America is supposed
to be is in decline. Well,
I know,
but if you keep a positive mental attitude
and try to effect change in any way
you can, you're, you're feeding into the
solution and not the cause. That's true.
You know what I'm saying? Like you can't
just go, fuck, this shit is shitty.
Let me just fucking high.
That is true.
But you got to own it head on and
everybody has got to do their part and get
positive with it. Where we're going
to build shit up. Yeah. Correct. Yeah,
that's right.
Give me some boy type music and I'm
just saying all of this deserves to get
pushed upwards and not just quit in
ours and motivation and get CEOs,
get them up there playing
the mayhem philosophy. I
yeah, I'm working on anyways.
Play time music. Yeah, you damn right.
I go out with those ankle bracelets or
listening to mayhem management is a side
one tape to,
you certainly should try to push for
positivity shirt and certainly should try
to push things in the right direction.
But at a certain point in
time you wonder like, man,
am I going to die and pot still
going to be illegal? Oh Man.
If you human [inaudible]
corrupt and it's like, it's,
I'm going to leave this earth exactly
the same way I came in. Knob is,
it's a fucking mess.
It's not going to,
pupils in my life made that
argument forever that you
got to do it again. Right?
It's like that was the good old quick
enough. Evolution's not quick enough. I'm,
I'm, I'm, you know, I feel like
it needs to catch the fuck up.
I think social evolution
needs to catch the fuck up.
The evolution of the human being and
its interaction with its environment,
it needs to catch up.
So you just technologies on this,
we're at this fever pitch of technology
and the human animal and it's all
ridiculous bullshit that it drags
along with. It is lagging behind.
That's what I think what I mean.
So eventually we're all
going to be plugged into the
computers like transcendent
man. Right? Most likely something
along those lines is going to happen.
It's just seems to me that
that's inevitable that our
integration is so fucking
complete as it is without it being
a part of our actual physical body.
You leave your fucking cell phone at
home and it feels like you left your Dick
in a jar.
It's going to be to the point where it's
an air plastic surgery is going to be
like taken out of your eye and upgrading
your eyes with the new night vision I
line and stuff like that.
Like you're going to likely replacing
parts on your body. Yeah, of course.
That'd be awesome.
But there's going to be people to cock
block all that stuff too because people
are afraid of science and
technology. Jesus people. Yeah,
but if there's money to be had in it,
it will probably exist as
long as it can be patented.
The real issue is when things are
awesome and people are scared of them and
they're not patentable like plants that
are psychedelic plants and that's the
reason why those things are illegal.
Because if psychedelic plants were just
a result of some fucking formula that
someone figured out in the
lab and he had a patent on it,
well by Jimminy cricket,
that Shit would be available to prescribe
for someone if they had some sort of
an ailment cause there's a fuck load
of money to be made from MDM a for
posttraumatic stress disorder.
If that shit was,
if somebody had created that and
owned it and it hadn't been demonized,
it would be for sure some something that
they would make a shitload of money off
of. You know, psychedelics are
coming back in medicine now.
There's a little slightly, yeah, there is.
Yeah. It's fascinating isn't it? Finally,
people are starting to accept the cancer
patients for a bunch of terminally ill
patients,
given one dose of mushrooms one time,
still 12 months later had significant
benefits for accepting what's going on
with people who've had cancer and taken
Iowasca and the cancer's gone into
remission because they believe that it's
completely altered the way they look
and think about their body and the way
they're allows their body to naturally
heal itself.
To be relaxed and system can function
correctly in a mall or something.
I'll ask you is that this
orally active form of DMT?
We talked about it so many
times in this podcast,
but for the people who don't
know what it is in the wood,
in the jungles of South America,
they've figured out a way to take the
leaves of one plant which contain DMT and
the vine of another plant,
which contains an Mao inhibitor,
which makes DMT or Iliac
breaking open the head. Yeah,
he definitely heard that day and do
that. And one of his shows, yes, he did.
He said he didn't get off.
He said it really. He said
it was interesting and cool,
but you know what I've heard from people,
especially from Mckenna,
used to talk about how when you
go down to the South America,
they have to really trust
you before the dose you up.
Like they don't want some crazy gringos
running around howling at the moon.
So they give you like week doses.
He knew,
he was saying that as the tourism of
these IOWASCA communities become more and
more prevalent as more and more people
go down to have this experience,
there's a lot of people that are having
bad trips and there's a lot of people
that are wary about the gringos.
So they come in and you come in with a
fucking camera crew and you're like, hey,
I want to try and tie Wasco and you've
got a ring on your thumb. You know,
like you've ordained does, they're
going to look in, you know,
give him some weekends. Shit. You know,
I don't feel like he
doesn't give you our God,
but if you,
if you have the strong shit,
I mean everybody says when you take
the strong shit that the experience is
undeniable.
So it seemed to me that like,
I've heard people have
DMT trips like that too.
I met a woman on the
plane back from Brazil.
That was the whole reason she was there.
Well,
they will tell you want go fry
was a spiritual journey. Yeah.
Well DMT is legal and it's
illegal in Brazil as well.
There's two different churches,
something University of Division
Division and another one that,
there's two different churches that use
a DMT as a sacrament along with, uh,
using, uh, Christianity. So they pray
about Jesus and then they take Iowasca.
Yeah, it's fucking nuts, man.
Interesting. Yeah, it's, but it's,
it's legal somehow or
another through some,
and it actually won in the Supreme Court.
So it's a Brazil. Yeah, no. In America.
In America, they brought it
over from Brazil. It's you,
they're accepted in Brazil and they're
accepted. This is their sacrament.
This I don't want.
So you can take this logistical under your
leg is straight and that, yes, I know.
Religious freedom, you can take it
and it's in the end of their sex in a,
I know for sure in New
Mexico. Yeah. But there's,
I think there's other places
in America to just convert.
Just take some DMT and sing songs
about Jesus. And when you're, you know,
when you're high on p and t,
the songs about Jesus,
well apparently they have
really strong stuff too. I've,
I have a friend who did it
and went through the, the
whole experience and said,
it's so bizarre. He said, first of all,
everyone's wearing uniforms that were
like the same clothes and they're wearing
uniforms and they're taking this really
strong DMT brew and they're singing
songs about Jesus. And they said, it's
like, what the fuck is going on here?
It's like, it's so weird. There's
so many different messages in there.
It's so strange. Yeah. Yeah. I'm a fan. I
would hate to be triple a ball and Jesus,
y'all or not,
man,
maybe you get used to it and you start
to like it and what Jesus represents to
you with something like super
duper positive and you know,
really loving and all knowing
and you know, and then,
and actually thinking about this thing,
you can actually manifest those
types of thoughts and ideas.
And then that's why they do it.
Yeah, I can understand that.
They can understand of being in a group
of people and no matter what it is,
just their use of Jesus as the term.
You guys are all like connected.
You know what I mean?
Like I feel I felt bad experience before.
Unfortunate they've ordained,
didn't get a good dose.
I would love to have here at his fucking
full blast off to the store cause the
alligators.
I don't want to go to the Amazon.
I would love to hear what people are
doing it here. First of all there's,
there's Shamans had been trained that
have come to America and I know where I
could do it here. I know a bunch
of people. I can do it here with,
you can do it here, especially in
Hawaiian as much people do it at Hawaii.
What's that? You're going to do
it in places. My, my point is,
is it like you don't have
to go to the five hours.
We're going to key sort of labor.
But you know,
this is one of the things we
want to talk to you about.
Before we were talking about
why I like to live in the woods.
You know why I would like to live
like way the fuck away from people.
I believe that one of the best reasons
why you take Iowasca in the jungle is
that you are in this place where the
energy of the plant and the experience,
it's, it all comes from this
one spot and that one spot,
it doesn't have a lot of Wifi signals. It
doesn't have pollution. It doesn't have,
this doesn't have cell phones fucking
flying through your ear and radiation.
It's just nature man. And there's a
silence that comes with like real nature,
you know? And all you hear is
animals and monkeys, deer hunting,
deer hunting was sitting in a tree stand
looking at a beautiful ridge just like
waiting and I'm going to kill you.
Just you're sitting there and it's just
so beautiful and they meditated. You're,
then you're sitting there and
the sun is coming up and man,
I could see it's super event.
Like you're like,
I just looking for any movement
or hear any sound. It's crazy.
It's like you're real predator.
You're really tuning into
boost and don't move.
I'm going to do Iowasca in a hospital
because that's where life and death is.
You know,
scratching,
scratching your face off in a
corner. Like, I dunno dude. Um,
I read about Mark Zuckerberg,
the guy who produced Facebook,
started hunting and gathering his own
food now because he wanted to take
responsibility for the food he ate and
he was just, can eat vegetables and nuts.
It's meat. He killed himself, so he
shot a fucking bison. Nice. You know,
I liked that. I liked that. I did, man.
You know, the, the hunter gatherer needs,
it's just like, it's very much like
the pussy needs. If you neglect them,
they'll go somewhere direction.
I think he's just practicing Facebook
to collapse. Yeah. He's like,
I need to figure out how to make food,
Facebook and civilization just,
he's got a compound, I'm sure by now.
That guy's got billions of dollars.
I was like some crazy ass money.
Killed it with a knife to to
say compounds of the way to go.
If you can afford it.
A big place where I said,
Oh, you might want to go deep,
deep, hi high fence compound. Can't
wait to, you're going to be awesome.
Patrol, the perimeter, whatever.
Dude, we're gonna write man. Wild
animals inside. That's what I mean. Yeah,
you're on fire truck. We
have mountain lions. Well,
there's a thing called the
firebreak system that you
can set up on roofs now and
what it is is when a
certain heat is reached,
they disperse this chemical all over
your roof that makes the house much less
vulnerable to fire.
So you've got to set things like that up.
If you're going to live in the woods,
you got to clear out the area all around
your house and make sure that you got
the fuck fucking most powerful fireproof
windows available and set up that fire
break system and then wait,
we're going to talk in here.
Make sure you can control your sprinkler
system to and all around the house.
And you're still, you're
probably fucked. He still,
you're probably fuck cause those
embers embers flies in the air.
They just land on shifts. Can't
put together. Oh yeah, I'm fine.
When the case happened,
I always used to stocked up waters
funded people up until two weeks ago,
number in San Diego, Orange County
of that blackout blackout happened.
I realized I got a three and a half
month old baby at home, a four year old.
My wife and I am completely
unprepared and you have no food.
I have no way to keep painting
called the annuity heat anything up.
Then I drove down the hill and it's dark.
Why live in Dana Point?
It's totally dark. Gas stations don't
work. Then I'm thinking, wait a minute,
I don't get that good a mileage on my car.
How quick till I run out of
gas and you can't pump any gas.
I think it would take four or five days
for things just to go complete store gas
at your house,
trashcan giant gas tank and have
your own gas at your house. Yeah,
that's legit. You could do it. Can you?
I'm sure you're allowed to take time out.
You're not allowed to have a bunch of gas
in your backyard. If you have a garage,
you shit you can do is you can keep your
own gas station in your house. Yeah.
You could fuel up,
get a gas tank that said farmers do it.
You're saying it to legal.
I think if you're a farmer you probably
can do it because that's your business,
but I don't think you can have a gas
station on your lawn. It's probably zoned.
It's probably,
that would be the dopest shit ever.
If you had your own gas station,
you would think that like Jay Leno,
they may be that.
You could do,
you could buy a shitty gas station and
just use it for your own personal gas.
Nah, Bro. Gas Stations,
it doesn't have a big of his house
and I'm imagining it actually,
am I making that up?
The gas stations ever go wonder gas
stations seem to be open all the time.
It was less than a guest. They should
went over. I guess they do. Some of them,
you know, I'll tell you in
downtown Boston, there's
no gas stations. It's true.
The two that were there
closed. It's true. It's true.
That's no cause we ran out of gas
on the way somewhere and I make it,
I have, you know, a little bit
left the car. We drove all around.
You notice like driving downtown Boston.
So we finally stepped you went to
the fire station and asked for gas.
Really? I had to hire a driver
cusp 50 bucks to drive me.
It took probably a 10 minute drive from
where we stayed in Bob and get some gas
and go back your car.
Yeah. Boston's a weird place with
zoning and shit too. You know, they're,
they really prize their
historical relevance, you know,
so you gotta be real careful
where you build things.
And it's a trip though
when you drive down,
you see those signs on some of the
buildings built in 1650 yeah, for sure.
Look at Beacon Hill. That whole
neighborhood was from like 1700 yeah.
And then nuts. That is nuts.
We're all walking around there.
I felt like I was back in time. A
budget. Beacon hills. Weird too,
because it isn't a lot of
it. Like apartments. Yup.
They're all old bank
building park right there.
Big buildings that are like houses
there. Sort of a more rural houses. Yeah.
Row houses connected to each other and
they were worth a shitload of money for
three, four, five, nine. Dot. And there's
no backyard, just get nothing. Nothing,
no backyard. Just to house jammed right
next to another house. It looks cool.
That looks cool. And across
the street there's a park. Yep.
I ran through that all the time. It
was crazy. The Boston Commons, crazy.
Great City city man. It's amazing.
Really awesome. Like you're, you know,
just to see all that old stuff,
you're just like shut the
ultimate busing experience.
Saint Paddy's Day dropkick Murphys,
guys like Robbie,
but on Saint Patty's Day was great.
Oh my God.
I'm going to England to Birmingham.
We're going to for the UFC in November
and I think I'm going to take a trip to
Stonehenge.
I'm going to go check that shit out.
I want to see some real old
monuments. Cool. What is
that anyway? Don't want meat.
They believe it's some sort of a calendar.
They don't know exactly who build it.
You know, it's a fascinating
little piece of sculpture.
It was just some caveman was like whatever
the good thing. Yeah. I mean that's,
but it is weird. It's a
weird, a weird structure. You
know. It's weird cause it's,
you know, how did they do,
like, could they, I don't know.
Is there was something strange thinking,
like how do they get that up?
They don't know, but probably leavers
and you know, probably in a system,
I use a bunch of trees over there before
when it was probably a big mountain and
they just carved it out out of the
mountain and it looks like they carried,
it did. There's a, there's a, um,
a crazy carving into the mountains
of a horse. You ever seen that?
It's like this white carving.
I don't know how the fuck they did it,
but it's carved and they don't even know
who did it. Just thousands of years old.
Wait is, where is that in England and
England? Yeah. Yeah. You know, there's,
there's stuff like that that they sort
of found and no one remembers how it got
there. You know, like a Stonehenge
is a, is a perfect example.
Like they found it and by the time
they found that when you know,
when modern times people found it,
they were like, what the fuck is this?
And everybody's like Dat. Yeah. What
the fuck is that? I can't remember.
It's so long ago. We were here for
years, been around for so long,
you know, and then they have crop circles
all over the place down there too.
It's such a freaky fucking little place.
We mean crops are going to crop circles.
You never seen crop circles.
Those designs it show up and wheat fields,
some of them. Oh they did that back in
the day. Yeah. And it's the ultimate,
it's the ultimate like what they are
for sure. A lot of them are hoaxes.
A huge percentage of the park.
Yeah. I thought the kids did that.
And when I say hoaxes, that doesn't mean
like the rest of them were made aliens.
But I think there's some,
there's some crazy technology involved
in it and I don't know if we have a full
assessment in accounting of all the
technology that the government or that
anyone you know at the highest level
of science really possesses right now.
I don't necessarily know,
especially when it comes to
military intelligence and
I think we've always had a
lot of secrets in this country and it's
very likely that there's things that can
produce crop circles.
Like they can shoot down a fucking laser
beam on a certain patch of earth and
create a pattern in the sand or in the,
in the wheat fields.
I don't think that's beyond
the realm of possibility.
If you can have nuclear weapons,
if you could have, you know,
international instant communication
via cell phone networks and data plans,
we could send photographs and videos to
another person on the other side of the
fucking world almost instantaneously.
I don't think it's beyond the realm
of possibility to think that you could
somehow or another imprint something from
a satellite, something flying overhead.
Who knows? I don't know.
And I don't know why.
You know what it might be simply someone
figured out how to do it and they
wanted to implement whether
or not they could, you know,
and then the ones they had it,
they just keep fucking with people.
If you had the patterns, if you could
make up all kinds of crazy shit,
why would my thing be like, hey,
I want to push it off a crops?
What's a good question? But like why
would I waste my talents on that?
If I was that smart, I would do something
way cooler. I make way more money.
You say that but listen, some of them are
hoaxes and some of them are beautiful.
These hoaxes are amazing.
I mean when I say hoaxes we know,
I mean there are human created works
of art, not a mystery whatsoever.
And these human creative works of art,
they've done like these guys
called the circle makers.
There's got a website called circle
makers.org brushed up and they, yeah,
will they give boards and they measure
things and they do these dope ass designs,
you know?
But what what they've done is,
you know what they've done is question.
You know,
it's shown that you can make
these crop circles on your own,
but some of them are weird man. Some of
them, like they show up in like an hour.
Like you have to believe
these people's reports,
which is sketchy at best of course,
but you're dealing with these people that
have no reason to lie. These farmers,
they fly over an area and then they
come back an hour later and there's
something that's three football fields
long and it's got 690 perfect circles in
an a varying sizes all in
some sort of a fractal.
You said that first sentence was like,
wait,
you're selling tickets
to see this at your farm?
He gets real attention whatsoever. Hey
guys, look at this crop circle. Oh my God,
it's a farmer who has the crops are 100%
and you listen. Some of them for sure,
definitely no question at all,
but some of them are gigantic and
most certainly would have been.
It would have taken enough time
that people would have known.
It's like they've hired people to do
them for advertisers and it's very time
consuming.
It's extraordinarily time consuming hurts.
You can't bang off these
giant things inside of, uh,
inside of an hour or whatever
the fuck these people are saying.
So if they're telling the truth,
then it could possibly be something else.
It doesn't necessarily have to be just
always people flattening boards out.
And I know there's a lot of other
science behind it in quotes,
science because they've, uh,
they've detected there's,
there's growth nodes and areas where
the stems of the plant has actually
exploded,
like it had been microwaved.
And then instead of just
being bent over these things,
these things have had some
almost boiled with energy.
You're saying their symptoms, like
sometimes it does that. Yeah, we're not,
and I want to say symptoms.
I'll say evidence that points to the
fact that this is all is all the shit.
By the way, hold on. This is all
shit that I've read on the Internet,
so I have no idea how much
of this is 100% legit.
But the idea is that what people
questioned about the crop circles,
the so called crop circle
experts and efficient models,
one of the things they point to is the
fact that there's an actual change in the
chemical structure of the plant
once it's been turned into this,
this circle that something has
happened to it. So it's been heated up.
Like I said, it could have been, it could
be some sort of technology if looks at,
say if you wanted to etch something
with lasers onto a piece of metal,
you know you could program a design into
a computer and that computer could act
something and if you had a laser
big enough and powerful enough,
it could be as big as my doom poster.
You can x some make some design with
a laser in that just using a computer.
Why couldn't you do that from a satellite
down on some fucking wheat field?
Of course you could.
It would just be just as possible.
I think if you've got the
potential to do it at close range,
and then we know there's a lot of shit
that we do at long range and we also know
that lasers,
you know,
a powerful laser doesn't really lose
its power over a long distance. Right?
Isn't that the case? Like these, these
laser things and one of the, one of like,
one of the things that's
dangerous about those laser pens,
it was really powerful ones.
Yeah.
You can point them at fucking planes
and they literally hit the cockpit car
plants. Yeah. Yeah. It's incredible.
And I wonder if the case
could be made that, you know,
if you could do that with a laser,
maybe you could do that with
something that mimics a laser,
but at some in some way or another
is like an amateur, a manipulator.
Darren does something. Yeah.
Who the fuck knows? I mean,
who at a certain point in time,
you've got to look at things that we
absolutely know. People who've done,
there's a goddamned space station up
there and they shoot rockets filled with
people and they go up and dock with this
thing and everybody's hanging out there
and partying the space. We
know that's real. You know,
as bizarre as that is shooting people in
giant metal tubes propelled by fire up
into the sky to doc with some floating
metal fucking machine that's up there.
The government is just like who
never texted us from ourselves.
Like we don't want you to know about
know awesome crop circle. But no,
I think there's a lot of things that
they do on the sneak tip like drones and
you know there's, there's, there's
bugs that look like, you know,
they look like bugs but they're spy
cameras and drones that are completely
unmanned minority report. Yeah,
I'll do, they've got some,
they've got some legit shit that looks
like little bugs and the flies around and
it can fly in Iraq.
You know,
I mean they've got some
incredible technology and you
would think that something
like this, like something that would,
you could make a crop circle with.
You could also use to do all
kinds of crazy shit with,
I mean if there's a sort of a technology
that can manipulate the patterns in
wheat fields,
like Tavi,
there's certain things you could do it
where it just barbecue someone out of the
fucking Sky B Cup circles are level
one. Yeah, that'd be great. Yeah.
Or it's just practicing where
it hits like the accuracy.
That's the market from
gears of war part one.
We could you imagine or have figure
out a way to have a satellite like that
flies over a city and then anytime you
want something done, it just zooms in.
Like Google Earth has an instant
closeup view of you and you disappear.
Just boom, fizzle, palm
bay up and that's it.
No person probably close,
pretty close. Probably close.
And the accuracy of establishing something
like what better way to demonstrate
the accuracy then make a fucking
design in a wheat field. Say, look,
we can do this. Have
people who know, dude,
that's a far reaching connection,
but so is everything that
we do every day that week,
the Internet based travel with. All
right, so you're discounting this though.
Everybody in their fucking brother
on the planet is a reporter now.
That's why the Arab spring sprung up.
Guess why?
Everybody's twittering each other
about how the fuck fuck this regime and
everyone's connected now. So now, okay,
so now we would know if somebody had a
technology to do something and it has
done it, they would. We would.
Somebody would know unless that technology
was created at area 51 and if that
was the case,
they have a long seated history of only
allowing people in there that absolutely
fucking know how to keep a secret because
there's a lot of shit that's gone down
in area 51 and very few
credible reports of any of it.
The doctor Robert Lasar might be the only
one and he's showing it to probably be
a liar.
The problem is people talk like you know,
just gave you an example area 51 dude,
there's thousands of people over decades,
decades of worked at area 51
developed by secret technology.
Somebody would want to get tested because
they're patriots because they believe
in this country because they work for
the military because that's a part of
their job.
They're a part of a big thing.
When you're a part of developing military
weapons, secret military weapons,
there's a certain amount of pride.
A lot of those guys take in the fact
that they are developing the very best
weapons and they're developing them in
secret in these fucking bunkers that are
built into the side of mountains.
Got To show the weapon though. Yes,
and they have, that's where the fucking
stealth bomber came from directly.
Area 51 there's a lot of nutty
shit that they worked on for years,
but this is this whole area. 51 they
didn't even admit it existed until,
I believe it was the 90s when they wanted
to spread the amount of land that they
controlled and was top secret because
too many people were getting close and
they were taking videos,
taking videos of what looks like
Ufo shows what it looks like.
Most likely unmanned drones flying through
the night air and dancing and doing
shit that we could never do on
a fucking airplane. She lifting.
There's a lot at JFK video
shit. A lot of it. No,
but once they start using it
though it makes the news. But dude,
they had to say that it existed in order
to get this extra land before that they
deny it as its existence. There was
no satellite Google earth back then,
so you couldn't say, show me what's going
on in in the Nevada desert, you know,
and then boom, you tune into like
a couple hours outside of Vegas.
There's this crazy fucking place called
groom lake and this is like a dried up
lake bed and the government is
fucking testing Ufo shows out there.
You know whatever Ufo is,
you know stealth bomber to me it looks,
I've seen them in real life.
It ever was Edwards Air Force Base.
We were filming factor out there.
That's a fucking Ufo man is black wing
thing flying over your head. That's,
that's like right out of star wars,
you know, does is allowed at all.
It was like any regular jet. It wasn't
unusually loud. It was far enough away.
It wasn't like right over my head
where it was like blood coming in low.
You know we were in Palm Dale Edwards.
Air Force base is like a little
bit outside of it. But you did get,
what makes the UFO awesome is it applies
super fast from middle of nowhere.
Like it just stop.
Like what makes you go that's Ufo is not,
it's flying and it sounds like a jet.
It's like the hummingbird shit
everywhere. And I, you know,
I always feed the lights in the sky
stuff and what we can't figure it out.
But like I feel like we can't
figure it out right now.
If somebody doesn't want us to know,
they're really not going to let us know.
I don't know what's,
I know you're really pumped on foot area
51 but I'm like well if we can't know
if they're going to tell us fuck
you, what can we really say? They're,
they're in charge.
It's a sexy idea.
It's something that's
fun and just keep around.
So the idea of Ufos and aliens,
Dude,
according to Dr Robert Alizar,
they tried to back engineer the
fucking craft and they couldn't. Man,
we don't have that element on earth.
It establishes without
beyond a reasonable doubt,
it's from another planet and their
dicks get hard with Geek knowledge.
They just want it to be an alien as fast.
I don't get it though. I'm just like,
all right cool cause the alien. I can't
wait bro, cause I want to play with them.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I want to see these things.
These guys just as fascinating to me
when something manmade does just as
fascinating too.
I think that's all it more for sure.
Because to me the fact that scientists
stood on top of scientists shoulders for
generations because it shit I
can't even understand. You know,
they just stood on top of each other
shoulder for generation read on this geeky
stuff that I don't have the
chance to read our bitten,
didn't let myself read like and then built
this or cure disease or that's crazy.
That's a beautiful big, to me that's
like the most important thing in society.
Like we should be really rewarding that
cause that's what's going to push us
forward. That's what you know. You
know what I'm saying? Exactly. Exactly.
Read bad. You got to do my white crew that
that's how much I love technology. Yes,
technology is awesome. I agree. Right?
Well that was the hard to sell you on.
I sorry Joe Rogan.
I didn't talk you up.
What kind of crazy?
A shitty,
you incorporate it into training now
cause I know that you're always at the
fucking the front of the line
when it comes to technology.
Every UFC we come back with a
couple of new drills for next week.
Like what's good,
what's high in the streets?
Shapes of the face or certain positions.
Like someone does something to go in
a minute that's there all the time.
And then you develop drills based
around that leads into like,
we started our whole ground and
pen stuff started like that.
Do you know the baby arm
of my pants?
What are you talking about? Baby
arm. It's the weirdest videos.
What's Tim Boetsch fought? Uh,
this past weekend, he fought, um,
nick ring and he had him in this position.
There's a position when
you're in side control,
when you're facing the guy's legs and
you got his leg or his arm rather wrapped
up in between your legs, you
know, that mounted crucifix.
Everybody likes to do it sideways. We sit
sideways in your face towards his, uh,
his, uh, legs and he grabbed his arm.
His arm is in between your legs like a
giant Dick called the baby arm that just
grab his wrist and you can break his arm.
It's right there.
It's right there on everybody. Nobody
does it. They just hold onto the arm,
but if you just grabbed that wrist,
you can completely control it
and you can just snap his elbow.
There's a tremendous amount of force in
that crazy leverage or show it to you.
Yeah. I want to show both his fight.
It's a John Jacques Machado move.
He invented it. Old School. It's old
school. You don't call it the baby arm.
He didn't call it the baby arm, but that's
Eddie Bravo named the baby. Of course,
John Talks like here from here to here,
I have his wrist.
This isn't on bar right here.
She dead easy.
I resilience have the coolest
accidents of all time.
I feel like the new up and coming kids
I feel like are not getting the really
the real experience of having
a Brazilian coach, right?
There's plenty act who barely speaks
English. The base. Look, look, look,
look for me. Book for me here. This was
the ish right here. Not Good. Not Good.
His time. He's something. No good. Push me
away. Push. We were push me where? Okay.
None that. Not that. Okay. I had it.
I had a viral,
it's called Jack Rave.
I pricked the coach for
Becker a day like that.
God gave me a Geeky and I was like,
Dang.
And it was so old and cross the other day.
Damn coach man,
like this is real math.
He's like Jeff Leatham.
When you get a horse for a presidency,
you don't watch his teeth. And I was like,
what? What the hell does that
mean? I don't even understand. Oh,
you get a hole or a gift horse. You don't
look at it in a mouth. Oh, I get it.
You don't want to eat.
I took classes at our Carlson
Gracie's and crossing,
didn't even speak English at
all. Oh, really? Didn't even try.
He would talk in Portuguese
and then Sergio Colon,
a dude who barely spoke English would then
give you, destroy your instruction. Aw.
So that's even better.
Or who we talked to John Awano and
John Juanelle speaks perfect English.
I wouldn't, you know what? I want to just
get a do to translate all my coaching.
Talking gibberish like does not like just
yelling and screaming and Ryan will be
like, he guys, he wants
to uh, to go front.
Headlocks right now you're like frustrated
when you hear certain dudes coaching.
Do you get frustrated with,
is it like Comedians, like
judge other comedians? Like,
Oh God, you went there. Yeah, some hack.
Shit. I'd like to say that didn't happen,
but probably some bro.
Dude. For your family. Yeah.
We ate all your folders by Brian.
Tell the truth.
If a guy has stupid coaching, we
do make fun of up, don't we? Yeah.
But that being said, I've said some dumb
stuff too. You know who my favorite guys,
my favorite guys to listen
to a as coaches, the English
dudes get the fucking,
they yell and scream and they do coaches.
I hope they're the same guys.
The Wolf's lair is
such an awesome acts. The English
accent is one of my favorite all time.
That's why we use it for infomercials
when they were trying to sell something
important,
they use an English accent because the
English accents like fucking legit man,
this is some serious fly fishing line.
I'm telling you the fly fishing line
all bit better than I'll ever meet the
highest quality brass hook.
Maybe that was a cue for something,
maybe that they rehearsed something
that in the gym it closed.
The distance means yeah,
do now we're going to a free,
he does.
He does a baby are,
and we do that sometimes.
So that's to say maybe there was spot on
and well rampage is so fucking talented
physically, but it's just so, you know,
everyone knows what he's going to do,
you know, and me and he'd be gets you.
You're fucked. If he gets a hold of you,
he puts those hands on you.
He could put it on anybody.
Rampage can put on anybody.
If you fuck up and you know you,
you let him get into his game and
and get ahold of you, you're done.
But Jon Jones,
man,
he figured out how to definitely not
let rampage fight as game. I mean,
that's what it was. It was rampage
flight. Jon Jones, his game,
he had a perfect fucking game plan
for his body and rampage. The style.
It's amazing to watch.
Wasn't that beautiful?
Does that inspire the fuck out of you
when you see shit like that? Yeah,
of course. I, you know, and
I felt like, uh, you know,
Jon Jones could it like a great job of
his gay plan and sticking to it and then
he took rampage out of his game plan
and didn't let ramp Hayes do what he was
good at. Do you know? It's great.
It was cool to watch that man.
It was like amazing. Amazing that he's
been able to do that so quick. You know,
it's fun to watch his evolution.
It's weird right now.
Who the fuck has ever gotten that
good that quick, you know? Nah. Yeah.
I mean that makes sense.
Let me, Stephan Bonner was,
what was that two years ago or
something like that? Was it even,
was it even two years ago? I
don't know. I'm just guessing.
I'm not going to go to search short
org and check it out. But you know,
when you're thinking about the
start fighting in 2008 yeah.
And when did he get to the UFC?
In 2009.
It was like nine months
later he had like six fights,
but they were fought really close.
It's amazing. So on another,
it's amazing when you watch it every now
and there's some dude who come along in
any sport where you just go,
Whoa, what the fuck? You know,
someone all of a sudden just jumps way
ahead of the Line Bay, you know, thick.
It's like a genetic mutation.
Yeah. When he beat up shogun dude,
that was literally like if you
were from another planet, okay.
And you, you came in and you
were watching these, uh, these,
these species, he would say, oh,
this is interspecies comeback.
This is one species going up against
another specie. Oh, this, this,
this shogun specie. This really can't
fuck with this other thing. Like,
why is he doing that?
That's like sort of like a grasshopper
fucking with a praying Mantis,
you know what I mean? You mean it would
have like two different things. You know,
I'm looking at Shogun,
the way he throws his punches
and the way he throws his kicks.
It's a guy who's got a an
arm that goes this long,
but when you've got an arm that goes
way the fuck across the room and it's
attached to a body that spent a lifetime
learning how to manipulate other
people's bodies and control them
and throw them around and wrestling.
It's literally a two different species,
you know? But it's fucking giant.
84 inch wingspan. Yeah, it is like
two different things. You go like,
well this is one thing. I guess they
could breed and they could have a child,
but really the different,
so you're, you're,
you're proposing the show got a judge
Jones bone? No repurposing that.
If we mixed up a female Shogun,
what do you think of this Chaz Bono
picture where she's walking around with no
shirt on? This is what I say. Oh wait,
where's that? She walks around outside.
It's hot out. So she's got these giant
scars where she used to have breasts,
so she had a breast meat removed and
now she's just flat chested but with a
woman's nipple. But she'd like belly.
She got like a lot of there. She's got a,
he's a footy game about Nancy
Grace's Nipper oh, shot.
That's all I was picking about the whole
entire time we were talking about this
bad thing.
Hello?
How Nancy Grace boobs stole the
tradies thunder by like, what the hell?
No, I don't even know what the big deal
is. I don't think of it as a trainee.
It's right when it's a girl. That term
becomes a guy. So she got to grow. I mean,
let she know what to the picture.
Just walking around that's
not even worth looking at.
So she's got a beard down.
I said, dude, you know, uh,
nipples. I don't know, man. I think
transgender people get a bad rap. I think,
you know, do whatever you want to do,
man. As long as that makes you happy,
if they're really does. However, I think
it's strange, the nipple thing that,
that's a real legit news source.
You would never be able to show a
photo of a woman's nipple before,
but because she has committed to the life
of a man now you could see her nipple.
That is what I found fascinating.
I think in America in general,
people just need to get over sex anyway.
Like I feel like it's like you make it,
you make it this scary dirty thing and
then show some titties on TV. Who Cares?
It's not going to,
you know,
I'm not going to send society
crashing down and burning.
I think people are worried
about people going nutty.
They're worried about people not
doing their share, not doing work,
not helping build up society.
And they think that one of the ways to
make sure and ensure that society keeps
moving at a good pace is to
control the sucks. What? Why?
Cause rolled the freak animal instinct
in people control the violence and
control the sex cause other, those are
the things that you most terrified about.
When the barbarian storm the gates,
you're not worried that they're going
to fucking take your basketball and now
they're worried you're going to fuck your
women and take your money. Why? Well,
I don't control. They couldn't try
and control sex and control violence.
Those are two things people try to
control when they want to keep society in
order. They tried to control sex
and control violence. Really?
I'd never thought about it that
way. Well that's, you know,
it's normal for people to want like,
oh look at these slots and these horrors
and I don't want to strip club near me.
You know, you have a whorehouse
in your town. What's, you know,
there's a natural inclination of what?
Why?
Why do you care if you're not fucking
these whores and why do you care while,
cause you don't want people near
you that are fucking these whores.
You don't want people in your neighborhood
then want to fuck these whores. Yeah,
but it's happening, right? Yeah.
But it's a natural inclination for
people to try to shy away from the most
frightening of our instincts there.
Our desire to want to fuck and a desire
to want to kill. Right. I guess so.
I guess you're right. I've never
really come to society. You,
your society for a young man
like you is like, you know,
might as well be Vegas all day,
you know,
but for the society to work in order for
people to show up at the wonder bread
factory,
you know,
in order for society to move and you
can't give it out and jobs at Starbucks.
I get where you're saying okay. He, yeah,
when you look at countries that are
more liberal, I wonder what their, uh,
their output is, their gross
domestic output or their, you know,
how well it was just like,
yeah, you go to Starbucks,
get a handy like overall
it's like, it's like, yeah,
it's like the society has
accepted like men, like in the,
in the sports pages
there's like naked chicks.
Like it's like whatever Lailey so you
can go and just get service somewhere.
In Japan
he is,
yeah,
I think you could just land places you
can go get jack on and it's like normal.
Like the guy bought him any,
any massage parlor.
But here it's so demonized.
Sometimes dudes do that.
The Broncos are legal and they're um,
about an hour. They as productive usage.
Japanese are more productive than
Americans. More desirable. Yeah, man.
And yet they can still
get jerked off places.
So that throws my theory to the delta.
Yeah. Totally crushes your theory.
That's why I was thinking about in
order to be creative. Hmm. Tom Man.
I think it just societal,
societal appropriately. Yeah.
It's like it might be, but why? How come,
why does Japan like really love America?
Why does,
why does so many Japanese?
Well, I'm not a lot of American
skin's really loved Japan as well.
I don't think they do it take a lot
of the music. Yeah. It's not dude.
There's a lot of people that are like
really get into American music over there
cause their music sucks so
bad. Is that what it is? Yeah.
I mean if you look at any country, like
most countries, music aren't there.
It's not as good as the United States.
Japan had his own grief.
You don't know what you're talking about.
I just talked to somebody the other day
that that went to Jab Japan probably
like 10 times and that's what
they were telling me this,
that's why I brought it up.
And every time they go there I I been
oil is American music or their version of
an old dude. I'm saying if
there's, okay so your country,
okay it's pretty bad ass and it makes
like a like good music and whatever.
But then another country who's budget is
way fucking bigger I think got crazier
acts of whatever crazy reveal affects
of course you're going to watch some of
that is not going to
totally be fuck America.
I was actually trying to get at the reason
why I was saying it is because I was
wondering what effect their, their
discipline and their, their, their,
you know the fact that they can get
laid and just get serviced with,
I wonder what that has
effect on their creativity.
Like the art day produced the music
that they make and I was like well why
do they like American music so much?
Is it, what is their music light?
Cause did they have like
really good music in Japan?
Is Japan like a dope ass Rockville,
j o j pop they or something like,
yeah,
there's different styles of
music like pop music, you know,
getting even one Japanese
artists right now named one that
you asked him,
name one American artists,
they know 50 well that's what I'm saying,
the dominant culture in the world.
A small island, they're not yet, but you
shouldn't even be able to no one. Oh Man.
God, because you don't
listen to Japanese music.
You don't understand the Japanese.
What I'm saying?
That's why they have no one's saying was
the singer. He's the best. Well yeah.
I mean I don't know though.
It's also a different language.
I mean we're not really interested in,
everybody in Japan speaks English a
little bit. Everybody speaks a little bit.
Everyone in Japan,
just about why a lot of people won't do
it because they feel embarrassed about
it. But everyone learns it
in school. So to an tech,
well maybe Japan because it's not
trying to take over the world anymore.
Maybe they've spent more time sort
of evolving as a culture like and uh,
you know, just progressing, you know,
business wise and discipline wise, no,
but I think for years and years it's been
just like that and people aren't just
like what? It's been like
that there's been a culture.
It's their culture back that whole
Geisha, Geisha before that even, you know,
and people had a normal, that was their
thing. Oh, I got a concubine. What's up?
That whole society's
patient, calm, conforming,
[inaudible] everyone dresses in the same
black suits. They do the same things.
They follow the same path.
Stepping outside of theF is really
frowned upon really front of mind.
You've got to be part of the team. Like
the team is smart, here's the rules,
do the rules. It's awesome. It's
fascinating. I think it's great.
I think people could adapt some of those
cultural Biggs from Japan and bringing
it here to him as possible.
It's very difficult.
Generations and generations now. How
do you think they want them doing that?
That's what it always been fast.
It was such a small amount of area of it.
So many people living in it, so they had
to be more disciplined. You eventually,
you got that way, you
became that way. Like,
because you know you do the
right even at Mcdonald's, man,
like they do the right job because
that's the right thing to do.
Don't get me wrong, there's stupid people
there. They can't help but they're dumb.
But they tried to do their job
as best as they can, you know?
And I feel like we could
bring that to America.
Just do your job like as best you can,
whatever your job is, do it awesome.
Like just try your hardest,
you know?
And I mean really that's
what you're trying to do.
That's what you should be trying to do.
But I think in America people are like,
oh, everyone owes me something. You know
what I mean? Like I should, you know,
I should get paid more. Like, no,
you shouldn't. You should just work.
You should just do what you have to do
and do it. Awesome. Because it's your job.
Jason Mayhem, Miller corporate
employer. I'm just saying, no,
no pep speech of the weak boys
took away your life insurance.
But I've got words of wisdom,
right.
You should just fucking work hard like
a wave. You got to do it. Do it hard.
Like do it as best you can.
Wait
for their back. I'd look at that.
Look at guns, germs and steel.
We talk about this book all the time.
Book ever. Yeah. How, just moving,
what geographic resources did you have in,
how did that affect how your
culture develops and the
Maori people with the best
in New Zealand, they fought all the
time cause they had lots of resources.
You could afford to have a priest to teach
her, uh, you know, just a home, whatever.
As soon as a group of those Maori people
move to an island, 400 miles south,
everyone had to spend
all day gathering food.
They had to work together
and you couldn't fight.
So they turned almost like this into a
peaceful culture. Sure. Not several year.
A hundred years later, the Mallory
come, they find them. What do they do?
They kill all, they're like the same
people. They're basically cousins,
pick them up, but we're the island
they went to has very few resources.
They had to spent all day gathering food
to eat a bunch of food in my house and
I can listen to him be appraised
so that I can go to a dot weekend.
I've spent it. We can have a
warrior's, we can have teachers.
All these specializations change a
society based on resource or resources or
their large grains that you could make.
Did you have domesticated animals?
Look at all that stuff.
Starting in a few regions.
Go try to domesticate a giraffe.
I do it with a goat.
I've got to last all that big.
Then all of a sudden with those animals,
you can live near them, so your diseases,
your immune system grows stronger.
You can make food.
You have surplus food and read this book.
I haven't read it.
It's the best GM hearing.
I haven't read it,
so that means it's been recommended
to me like blow your mind.
I'm going to get it on Amazon right now.
All right, good. Good. Yeah, I think go.
I don't, I don't remember the
whole Japanese part of a bed.
Be Interesting to watch the ancient
aliens the other night where they were
trying to say that Japanese
Samurai swords, they were
talking to them by aliens.
Awesome. No one could have figured out
a way to make this steel like this.
They were talking about develop
the ability to fucking folds.
Samurai sued given to me
by ass freaking alien dude.
It was glow in the dark. It that'd be
like four Chan Chan's been doing with him.
They've been having huge photo threads
of the guy felt aliens like his hair and
stuff and they're just like making him
like all these different characters like
it's so fucking, I love websites. So
funny. I want to get all four term.
I always hear about it. I never go
on it from Starbucks. Buy Now what?
One click sudden Bam a bought a gun.
Germs and steel.
I'll try to read it in the next time
you're on the podcast can bring that shit.
Yeah, it's out of your work. You
know what? Actually the first half.
That book is pretty like
ball ball, ball, ball, ball.
Then it gets to be like work
like the second one. Yeah,
the second half you started
to be like, aw, Shit.
Like I got to read this back again. It
all gets a little complicated, but man,
overall like I'm sold. That's one
of the books I'm so glad I read.
It paints a beautiful picture on why did
Europeans come over to different places
in world, spread their journey.
You know, Columbus stuffed up,
the boat sneezed and
100 million people die.
Why didn't Indians getting native
Americans here? Getting to canoes, come
to Europe. In fact, this would their
diseases and shoot us with. Well,
there's a lot of people that believe that
people came here far earlier than that.
You know what the old Mex are and
a in Mexico and in South America,
you ever heard the old macs? They
don't know what the fuck they are, man.
They don't know who they are,
where they have an African faces.
They have African faces and these things
are thousands and thousands years old.
They believe at least 6,000 years old.
He's fucking structures,
which puts them more, what does
that 4,000, not even, yeah.
Well almost 4,000 BC. So they don't
know who the fuck these people were,
where they came from. Africa, they have
African faces on this big carved stones,
gigantic,
massive ones that these faces.
They don't have a language
attributed to these people.
They don't know anything about the
culture. Sorry, just what a mystery.
So it's very likely that people were
traveling from, uh, from South America,
South America to Egypt.
In fact,
because they found cocaine in mummies
and they know the cocaine can only been
grown in South America and South America.
Whole Mormon faith belief though, right?
No,
the Mormon faith believes that the lost
tribe of Israel came across the Bering
strait and they became
the American Indians. Uh,
I went thought that South America first,
they believe, well, maybe, I don't know.
They think that's how it was
described to me by a Mormon.
Is that somehow somewhere
in the Middle East,
they came to South America first and
populated the Americas from stem.
I haven't heard that one.
I thought what I heard,
maybe there's another
group that believes that,
but what's really funny is
one guy actually went and
got genetic testing because
he was a devout Mormon and he
really truly believes in it.
So went out and got the American Indians
tested cause he wanted to prove that
they were Israeli. You know,
there were the lost tribes,
but they were from Siberia.
They were from the Bering strait.
They came from another country. They were
Indian. Well you don't need a damn test.
Look, look at to ask about,
I look at a Chinese person,
you're like, ah, there's gotta
be some damp connection. Yeah.
Russians look so much like American
Indians, you know, easy. Yeah.
Well there's the those,
you know, those people,
it's really amazing when you stop and
think about it when you look at like how
Eskimos have lived, you know,
up until really recently,
I mean he's still sort of follow the
same sorta lives that they would have,
have to have followed hundreds
and hundreds of years ago
to stay alive. You know,
they still were skins, you know, they
still, they hunt seals, you know, it's,
it's kind of a amazing shit that they're
still able to eke out a life in a world
where you would be terrified to live.
Could you imagine if we had to go and we
had a move to like northern Alaska and
live forever with the Eskimos,
like Whoa,
that's a trivial at this point in your
life I would try my best question.
Good question. I would try
my best. I'll be like, fuck
it dude. Let's get out there.
Let's do some ice fishing.
I though it'd be our first
thought like get some books, Bro.
I want to get some furry boots to the
real boots is where it's at the season.
The real issue would be that you'd have
no choice and that you would probably
have to be working so hard
just to stay alive. Oh yeah.
That's where you must get
all of your enjoyment from,
from fucking hunting and gathering.
Like you don't have no time
for no hobbies anymore. Dude.
If you're living up there and you're
just trying to bash seals over the head
every day and he was a reserve I think.
I think you would,
you would adapt just like any movie
like that Tom Hanks movie where you feel
like that's crazy.
You would adapt but you wouldn't enjoy it.
There's this weird life.
Could be this podcast life
drink coconut juice.
Thank you to CTO cause they sent me
some juice and stuff is the bomb diggity
it's delicious but know what I mean?
Come on Jill Rowley.
It's super healthy for you. Yeah. Ryan
Parsons. Yeah it is right isn't it?
You're the health master. I'm know
about that but yeah, that's great.
Do you still sell that life force stuff?
I do life force, right? Not Light Force
and then l I f f e is the Randy couture
version. I don't think that exists.
Say More, but I'm not sure. I
think, I think he has a different,
where did they get that light force?
Shit they got that stuff's good.
Light four screens. Dot. Everybody
was drinking that shit for a while.
I can't give it.
I was drinking with my protein shake.
It gives a look a little bit flare
to, yeah, that's what I do to a,
to then I also buy some,
there's a green superfood thing.
Powdered shit always put it in there,
but I don't know how
much that really helps.
It doesn't ever seem to help as much as
the Vitamix when you really blend it up
like rocky now and will be a fresh juice
or at Vitamix juice I powder is dam can
be, it's good to travel and things
like an extra little boost. Do you,
I'm always feed your gut and make sure
you guys eat red meat or do you got,
do you guys eat chicken and fish?
Like what do you, do you uh,
do you stop them from eating red meat?
What do you, what's your diet? To me,
I spent so much time on and it's a
subject that's really interesting and it's
super boring at the same time because
in 30 seconds you can learn 95% of
everything you need to know and
then you can argue about the rest.
So I think less, you know, red meat
is probably better. I got an idea.
I think, uh, you supposed to eat
things that are hard to catch.
I think that's why fish is really good
for you and that's why dear is really
good for you and is really good for her
because they're out there running and
trying to get away. It's so
different than anything. Farmer.
Super good flights are good. Yeah, super
good for you. That's what I'm saying.
Essential fatty acid profiles are
totally different than that profile.
Everything is better for you.
Chickens that fight back like that.
That's it. There's a big fat plump
ones with a juicy breasts. The,
their breasts are so big to fall forward
and fucking face plant everywhere they
go. You ever seen those? Those are
American chickens, Jack. That's crazy.
Then when they get there real quick,
you know,
they're trying to take a chicken and
there's, there's ideas of chicken,
a chicken and turn into a dinosaur.
Like they,
they believe that they can actually
do some Jurassic Park Shit.
What the hell are we waiting for?
I want to see this chicken
chicken source. Rex. I want to see
it. Jurassic Park was a bad ass. Fuck.
That movie made me like,
man, I hope they do the food.
When that fucking kid is in the car and
the water starts here and then the clock.
I used to do a little, what's that?
And you see that fucking thing.
Holy Shit. Val. Joe Rogan, who's
scared of animals don't exist.
Terrifying animals just in
the future. How about that?
You wouldn't go to Jurassic Park about
new predators. I just gotta go. Joe Rogan.
Would I go to dressers? Drastic Park.
Would you go? Is there a t rex? Yes.
No, I'm not going. Come on Bro.
Damn breaks loose. So I see a t rex.
He racks ma'am. Trx on the Grassy Park
movie. The movie. I saw it. T rex.
I've got a big screen TV man.
So legit high definition,
10 ADP. We got a lot route this bitch
up because we're running out of tape.
Oh Man. As we won't be able
to process it on iTunes.
But this was a long and storied
discussion. It was, you guys are awesome.
Thank you Dr. Parsons for
coming by and hey, by the way,
best Netcracker and the history of neck
cracking cracked the shit ass. And next,
he's an awesome chiropractor as well.
And uh, of course the broken trainer of,
what do you call yourself, Beth? What
do you guys call yourselves? Reality,
reality show flow.
I don't name her name man.
We need to come up with a name when
named for the Ryan Parsons Team,
the Ryan Parsons posse.
Isn't there a song? A band?
The Ryan Parsons project is Allen Park.
That's your cousin's son this weekend I'm
in Washington DC at the Warner Center,
a nine 30 this Friday night.
And that's with Ari Shaffir.
And then on October 7th, we're in Houston,
Texas at the Verizon Wireless Center.
And that's with Brendan
Walsh and Joey Diaz.
And that should be fun as fuck you've
Goddamn fucking freaks for what we talked
about earlier. Alpha brain,
if you're interested,
go to [inaudible] dot com and if
you enter in the code named Rogan,
you will get 10% off and thank you to
the fleshlight for sponsoring the podcast
as well.
And then if you go to Joe rogan.net and
click on the link for the flashlight and
enter in the code name rogue,
and you get 15% off some saving you money
while I'm straight and not your brain
and sharpen it up your loads,
whoever thought your last name
would be a coupon code growing up.
Crazy shit is crazy to me.
Subscribe to the death squad on iTunes.
It's Brian's podcast network
that he's got going on with.
He's got John Reap and
John half rotten or on,
and he got Tom Segura on that.
Sam Tripoli,
a bunch of good comics and it's all
free, of course. And that's it, right?
So we're probably going to be
back tomorrow, but I don't know.
I have to find out what time to work til,
but that's it for now.
Thank you everybody. Thank
you Brian. Thank you ma'am.
Thank you all the people out
in cyber land and remember,
I love you bitches.